hello everyone and welcome back to our
Channel your goto destination for all
things related to cyber security and
technology and today we are diving into
an essential topic that's at the core of
cyber security networking whether you
are just starting your journey into the
world of cyber security or looking to
enhance your skills understanding
networking is a fundamental aspect of
keeping digital environment secure in
this video we'll uncover the basics of
networking explore how it's critical in
the context of cyber security and
provide you with the knowledge and tools
you need to protect your digital assets
effectively but before we dive in if you
want to become a networking expert and
gain handsome salary packages look at a
wide range of cyber security courses and
networking courses by simply learn in
collaboration with top universities
across the globe by enrolling in any of
these certification programs we will
gain expertise in skills like IDs
fireballs and honey ports Network packet
analysis security and risk management
identity and access management software
development security Trojan's back doors
and counter measures mobile and web
Technologies and there's much more on
the list with hands-on experience and
tools you will catch the eyes of top
recruiters so what are you waiting for
hurry up and enroll now a year of
experience is preferred to enroll in
these courses you can find the course
Link in the description box below and
pin comment and make sure to hit that
subscribe button and ring the
notification Bell so you won't miss any
of our upcoming tutorials and
discussions on cyber security and
Technology are you ready to boost your
cyber security knowledge and become a
networking expert well then let's get
started an introduction to network
security network security is a set of
technologies that protects the usability
and integrity of a company's
infrastructure by preventing the entry
or proliferation within a network it
architecture comprises of tools that
protect the network itself and the
applications that run over it effective
network security strategies employ
multiple lines of defense that are
scalable and automated each defensive
layer here enforces a set of security
policies which are determined by the
administrator beforehand this aims at
securing the confidentiality and
accessibility of the data and the
network the every company or or
organization that handles a large amount
of data has a degree of solutions
against many cyber threats the most
basic example of network security is
password protection it has the network
the user chooses so recently network
security has become the central topic of
cyber security with many organizations
involving applications from people with
skills in this area it is crucial for
both personal and professional networks
most houses with highspeed internet have
one or more wireless routers which can
be vulnerable to attacks if they're not
adequately
secure data loss theft and sabotage risk
may be decreased with the usage of a
strong network security system your
workstations are protected from
hazardous FW thanks to network security
additionally it guarantees the security
of the data which is being shared over a
network by dividing information into
various sections encrypting these
portions and transferring them over
separate Pathways network security
infrastructure offers multiple levels of
protection to th man in the middle
attacks preventing situations like
eavesdropping among other harmful
attacks it is becoming increasingly
difficult in today's hyperconnected
environment as more corporate
applications migrate to both public and
private clocks additionally modern
applications are also frequently
virtualized and dispersed across several
locations some outside the physical
control of the IT team Network traffic
and infastructure must be protected in
these cases since assaults on businesses
are increasing every single day we now
understood the basics of network
security but we need to understand how
network security works in the next
section in slightly more detail network
security revolves around two processes
authentication and
authorization the first process which is
authentication is similar to access
cards which ensure that only those have
the right to enter a building in other
words authentication checks and verifies
that it is indeed the user belonging to
the network is trying to access or enter
it thereby preventing unauthorized
intrusions next comes
authorization this process decides the
level of access provided to the recently
authenticated
user for example Network admin needs
access to the entire network whereas
those working with the net probably need
access to only certain areas within the
network based on the network users role
the process of determining the level of
access or permission level is known as
authorization today's Network architect
is complex and faces a threat
environment that is always changing and
attackers that are always trying to find
and exploit
vulnerabilities these vulnerabilities
can exist in many areas including
devices data applications users and
locations for this reason many Network
Security Management tools and
applications are in use today that
address individual
threats when it's just a few minutes of
downtime can cause widespread disruption
and massive damage to an organization's
bottom line and reputation it is
essential that these protection measures
are in place
beforehand now that you know a little
about network security and its working
let's cover to the different types of
network
security the fundamental tenant of
network security is the layering of
protection for massive networks and
store data that ensure the acceptance of
rules and regulations as a whole there
are three types the first of which is
physical security the next being
Technical and the third being
administrative
let's look into physical security first
this is the most basic level that
includes protecting data and network to
unauthorized Personnel from acquiring
control over the confidentiality of the
network this include external
peripherals and routers that might be
used for cable connections the same can
be achieved by using devices like
biometric systems physical security is
critical especially for small businesses
that do not have many resources to
devote to security personnel and the
tools as opposed to large
firms when it comes to technical network
security it focuses mostly on
safeguarding data either kept in the
network or engaged in network
transitions this kind fulfills two
functions one is defense against
unauthorized users the other is a
defense against malevolent
actions the last category is
Administrative this level of network
security protects user Behavior like how
the permission has been granted and how
the authorization process takes place
this this also ensures the level of
sophistication the network might need to
protect it through all the attacks this
level also suggest necessary amendments
that have to be done to the
infrastructure I think that's all the
basics that we need to cover on network
security in which our next topic we're
going to go through two mediums of
network security which are the transport
layer and the application
layer so transport layer is a way to
secure information as it is carried over
the Internet with users browsing
websites emails in messaging Etc TLS
aims to provide a private and secure
connection between a web browser and a
website server it does this with a
cryptographic handshake between two
systems using public key cryptography
the two parties to the connection
exchange a secret token and once each
machine validates this token it is used
for all Communications the connection
employs lighter symmetric cryptography
to save bandwidth and processing power
since the application layer is the
closest layer to the end user user it
provides hackers with the largest threat
surface poor app layer security can lead
to Performance and stability issues data
theft and in some cases the network
being taken down examples of application
layer attacks include distributed denal
of service attacks or DDOS attacks HTTP
floods hql injections cross-site
scripting Etc most organizations have an
arsenal of application layer security
protections to combat these and more
such as web application firewalls secure
web Gateway Services Etc now that we
have the theory behind network security
has been covered in detail let us go
through some of the tools that can be
used to enforce these network security
policies the first tool to be covered in
the section is a firewall a firewall is
a type of network security device that
keeps track of incoming and outgoing
Network traffic and it decides which
traffic to allow or deny in accordance
to a set of security rules the most more
than 25 years firewalls have served as
Network Security's first line of defense
they provide a barrier between
trustworthy internal protected and
regulated networks from Shady external
networks like the internet at some point
the next tool which can be used to
bolster network security is a virtual
private Network or VPN for short it's an
encrypted connection between a device
and a network via the Internet the ened
connection AIDS the secure transmission
of sensitive data it makes makes it
impossible for unauthorized parties to e
drop on the traffic and enables remote
work for the user the usage of VPN
technology is common in both corporate
and personal networks next we cover the
importance of intrusion prision systems
in network security or IPS Frameworks an
intrusion prevention system is a network
security tool that continually scans a
network for harmful activity and
response to it when it does occur by
reporting blocking or discarding it it
can be either Hardware or software it's
more sophisticated than an intuition
detection system or an IDs framework
which can just warn an administrator and
merely identify harmful activities while
in the case of an IPS it actually takes
against that activity the next tool in
this section and the final one are going
to be behavioral analytics behavioral
analytics focus more on the statistics
that are being carried over and stored
through months and years of usage once
some kind of similar pattern is noted
but the it administrator can detect some
kind of attack the similar attacks can
be stopped and the security can be
further
enhanced now that we have covered all
that we need to know about network
security the necessary tools it's
different types Etc let's go through the
benefits of network security as a
whole the first which is protection
against external threats the objective
for cyber assaults can be as varied as
the Defenders themselves although
they're typically initiated for
financial gain whether they are
industrial spies activists or cyber
criminals these Bad actors all have one
thing in common which is how quick
clever and covert the attacks are
getting a strong cyber security posture
that considers routine software updates
May assist firms in identifying and
responding to the abuse techniques tools
and the common entry
points the next benefit is protection
against internal threats the human
aspect continues to be the cyber
security systems weakest link Insider
risk can originate from current or
former workers third party vendors or
even trusted partners and they can be
unintentional careless or downright even
aside from that the rapid expansion of
remote work and the personal devices
used for business purposes while even
iot devices in remote locations can make
it easier for these kind of threats to
go undetected until it's too
late however by proactively monitoring
networks and managing access these
dangers may be identified and dealt with
before they become expensive disasters
the Third third benefit is increased
productivity it is nearly impossible for
employees to function when networks and
personal devices are slowed to a crawl
by viruses and other cyber attacks
during the operation of website and for
the company to run you may significantly
minimize violations and the amount of
downtime required to fix the breach by
implementing various cyber security
measures such as enhanced firewalls
virus scanning and automatic backups
employee identification of possible
email fishing schemes suspicious Lings
and other malicious criminal activities
can also be aided by Education and
Training another benefit is brand trust
and
reputation customer retention is one of
the most crucial elements in business
development customers today place a
premium on maintaining brand loyalty
through a strong cyber security stance
since this is the fastest way to get
other businesses back get referrals and
sell more tickets overall additionally
it helps manufacturers get on the vendor
list with bigger companies as a part of
the supply chain which is only as strong
as its weakest link this opens
possibilities for potential future
endeavors and development today we take
you to the future of networking in this
tutorial video we are going to get on an
exciting journey into the dynamic world
of network engineering specifically
focusing on how to become a network
engineer in the year 2024 with
technology evolving at an unprecedented
Pace the role of network Engineers has
never been more crucial we will uncover
the latest industry Trends Cutting Edge
Technologies and essential skills that
you need to thrive in the ever evolving
landscape of networking whether you're
just starting or looking to level up
your skills join us as we unlock the
secrets of a successful network
engineering career in 2024 and beyond
that said if these are the type of
videos you'd like to watch then hit that
subscribe button and the bell icon to
get notified and and if you are a
professional with minimum one year of
experience and an aspiring cyber
security professional looking for online
training and certifications from the
prestigious universities and in
collaboration with leading experts to
enhance your credibility then search no
more simply learns post-graduate program
in cyber security from MIT University in
collaboration with EC Council should be
the right choice for more details head
straight to our homepage and search for
postgraduate program in cyber security
from MIT University or simply click on
the link in the description box below
now without further delay over to our
training so without further delay let's
get started by discussing the agenda for
today's session first we will understand
who is an network engineer followed by
that we will learn the important skills
required for you to become a network
engineer then we will go through the
rules and responsibilities of a network
engineer then the most important point
of today's discussion that is how to
become a network engineer or the road
map to become a network engineer
followed by that we will discuss the
salary compensations offered by the
major emenes to a network engineer and
we will wrap up the discussion by
discussing some of the biggest mnc's
which are hiring Network Engineers as of
now now let's get started with the first
pointer which is who is a network
engineer computer network Architects and
Engineers design and build data
communication Network and monitor
Network systems these could range in
size from a connection between couple of
offices to an intricate Cloud
infrastructure serving a multinational
company Network Engineers are often also
responsible for protecting these
networks from all sorts of external
threats from fishing schemes to
ransomware to denial of service attacks
with a process known as network security
at smaller companies you may be
responsible for both architecture and
security working in larger companies
often means specializing in one area of
network engineering such as architecture
security or Administration
now moving ahead we will learn the
important skills required to become a
network engineer Network Engineers
require a diverse set of skills to
effectively design Implement and
maintain Network infrastructure here are
the top five important skills for a
network engineer first networking
fundamentals a strong understanding of
networking Basics is essential this
includes knowledge of network protocols
such as DCP IP DNS DHCP and HTTP as well
understanding how data travels through
networks is also critical this
fundamental knowledge forms the basis of
more advanced networking tasks next is
routing and switching Network Engineers
need to be proficient in configuring and
managing routers and switches this
involves understanding routing protocols
like OSF and bgp as well as we Lans
spanning tree protocols and other
switching Technologies they must be able
to design and troubleshoot complex
Network architectures as well next is
Network security security is critical
aspect of modern networking Network
Engineers need to be well versed in
network security best practices this
includes knowledge of firewalls
intrusion detection and prevention
systems VPN and the ability to identify
and mitigate security threats and
vulnerabilities cyber security
certifications like certified
information system security profession
are also known as
cisp can be valuable next ahead is
network monitoring and troubleshooting
Network Engineers should be skilled in
using network monitoring tools to
proactively identify issues and maintain
Network performance they need to
troubleshoot network problems
efficiently often under time constraints
knowledge of tools like wi shark and
SNMP is helpful and the ability to
analyze Network traffic is a valuable
skill lastly communication and
collaboration effective communication is
essential as Network Engineers often
work with cross functional teams and
need need to explain complex technical
issues to non-technical stakeholders
collaboration skills are crucial when
working with other it professionals such
as system administrators Security
Experts and application developers
moving ahead we will discuss the
important roles and responsibilities of
a network engineer Network Engineers
play a crucial role in designing
implementing and maintaining the
infrastructure that allows organizations
to communicate and function effectively
here are five important roles and
responsibilities of a network engineer
firstly Network design and planning
evaluate the organization's Network
requirements and Design Network
Solutions that meet the needs plan and
architect Network infrastructure
including choosing the right Hardware
software and protocols consider
scalability redundancy and Security in
network design next is Network
implementation configure and deploy
network devices such as routers switches
firewalls and load balances set up
virtual private networks or VPN for for
secure remote access install and
maintain network cabling ensuring it
meets industry standards the third one
is network maintenance and
troubleshooting monitor Network
performance traffic and security to
identify and resolve issues promptly
Implement Network updates patches and
firmware upgrades to ensure Optimal
Performance and security troubleshoot
network problems including connectivity
issues latency and packet loss the
fourth role and responsibility is
security and compliance implement
security measures to protect the network
from cyber threats including configuring
firewalls intrusion detection systems
and encryption protocols ensure
compliance with industry standards and
regulations such as gdpr Hippa or PCI
DSS depending on the organization's
needs conduct security Audits and
vulnerability assessments to proactively
identify and lastly we have
documentation and Reporting maintain
detailed documentation of network
configurations changes and diagrams
create and update Network documentation
which is essential for troubleshooting
and ensuring consistency generate
reports or network performance of time
and security incidents for management
and compliance purposes in addition to
these roles and responsibilities Network
Engineers often collaborate with other
it and non-it teams within an
organization to ensure that the network
supports the business goals and
objectives they must also stay updated
with the latest Technologies and best
practic to keep the network secure and
efficient in the face of evolving
threats and changing business needs now
the important point of Crest discussion
that is how to become a network engineer
so the first step is education obtain a
bachelor's degree in computer science
information technology or a related
field while a degree is not always
mandatory it can significantly improve
your chances of securing a job
additionally taking courses in
networking cyber security and
Telecommunications can provide a solid
foundation next next one is gain basic
it experience start by gaining
experience in basic it rules such as
technical support to develop a strong
understanding of computer systems and
troubleshooting this will help you grasp
fundamental concepts before specializing
in networking third one is develop
networking skills learn about networking
fundamentals including Network protocols
routing and switching landan or van
Technologies and network security online
courses tutorials and self-study can be
useful in acquiring these skills moving
ahead we have certifications pursue
industry recognized certifications such
as Cisco certified Network associate or
also known as CCNA or comp TI network
Plus or Juniper Networks certified
associate also known as
jncia these certifications validate your
Knowledge and Skills in networking and
can make you more competitive in the job
market moving ahead we have the fifth
step which is hands-on experience gain
Hands-On exper experience by setting up
and managing small networks at home or
through internships practice configuring
routers switches and fireballs and
troubleshoot network issues to enhance
your practical skills now moving ahead
we have the sixth step stay updated stay
informed about the latest networking
Technologies Trends and best practices
through online forums industry
Publications and networking events
continuous learning is crucial in
rapidly evolving field of networking now
the seventh step that is soft skills
develop strong communication problem
solving and teamwork skills Network
Engineers often work in teams and need
to communicate effectively with both
Technical and non-technical stakeholders
eighth one is to specialize consider
specializing in specific areas such as
network security Cloud networking or
Wireless networking to enhance your
expertise and career prospects the ninth
step build a network attend industry
events seminars and workshops to expand
your Professional Network networking
with Professionals in this field can
provide you with valuable insights and
potential job opportunities lastly apply
for jobs look for an entry-level
position such as network technician
Junior network engineer or network
administrator to Kickstart your career
update your resume and Linkedin profile
to highlight your skills and
certifications remember becoming a
network engineer is a continuous Journey
if you are in India and if you're a
beginner level network engineer then you
can expect salaries ranging from 250,000
to 450,000 per anom if you're an
intermediate candidate with 1 to two
years of experience then you can expect
salaries ranging from 450,000 to 8 lakhs
per anom and if you're a highly
experienced candidate that is experience
more than 4 years then you can expect a
minimum salary of 8 lakhs to 20 lakhs
per anom and if you're in America and if
you're a beginner then you can expect
salaries in ranging from $50,000 to
$80,000 per Anum and if you're an
intermediate candidate with minimum 2
years of experience then you can expect
salaries from $80,000 to
$110,000 per anom and if you're a highly
experienced candidate that is more than
four years of experience then you can
expect salaries ranging from $110,000 to
$160,000 per an now with this let us
move on to the top companies hiring
Network Engineers some of the biggest
Tech joints hiring Network engineers in
the industry are Cisco systems Amazon
web services Microsoft Google Facebook
or meta IBM AT&T verison Communications
D HP and much more
ethernet ethernet is a form of
communication Network that uses a wired
medium to connect devices for data
Exchange in a network for example Lan
also known as local area
network also van known as wide area
network
ethernet also applies different protocol
on the data to be transmitted over the
communication Channel efficiently and
smoothly moving on let's look into why
to use
ethernet as we now know the ethernet is
a mode of connection for multiple
devices to share and exchange data but
using this way of transmission also has
its benefit for example
the ethernet Network provides us with a
high-speed connection for sharing
data ethernet also provides the user
data with a secure channel for
transmission the data that is
transmitted over the ethernet channel is
reliable and has rarely faced any issues
at the cender
side let's move on to the next
heading now we will look into different
types of ethernet
in general the ethernet is divided into
three different types first is the fast
ethernet this type of ethernet operates
on a twisted pair cable with the data
transmission speed of up to 100 MVPs per
second fast ethernet connections are
used for personal connections or used in
companies that require low internet
connection moving on we have gigabit e
inter this connection is used for
highspeed internet connection with a
speed ranging from 1,000 Mbps to 1
gbps it is an upgraded form of fast
ethernet and the last type is Switched
ethernet this ethernet type installs
network devices such as switches or hubs
so as to improve the network
transmission the transmission range for
switched ethernet connection is is
around 1,000 Mbps to 10
gbps now let's look into the working of
ethernet ethernet Services is
specifically work in the first layer of
the OSI model that is known as the
physical layer and the second layer of
the USI model also known as data link
layer functioning of the ethernet can be
divided into three different parts first
step being acquiring the physical
address that is Mac address media Access
Control address of the sender and the
receiver
device then the second step is to check
the data security quality of the data
and the connection speed of the
transmission channel for efficient and
smooth transmission of data over the
network and the last step is to check
Network traffic and detect any error
that occurs in the communication
channel to solve these issues if occur
csma protocols and other Protocols are
used for example the csma protocol is
used in case of packet Collision in the
network
channel now let's look at a simple
ethernet model for further clarification
of the
steps but before we begin with the model
the point to be noted is the
transmission of data over the e internet
channel is divided into two
parts frames and packets where packets
represents a unit of data in the network
whereas frame refers to the collection
of data packets being transmitted over
the
channel and the application of ethernet
Services which includes security traffic
check and protocols being applied on the
data and that is when it reaches the
receiver
varent moving on let's look into
advantages and disadvantages of using
ethernet for advantages we have cost of
installing ethernet connection is low in
comparison to other network
channels the security of the data being
transmitted over the ethernet channel is
maintained as for disadvantages we have
it is suitable only for establishing
short
communication Network due to high
requirement of Hardware
resources whereas ethernet is also not
suitable for sharing realtime data and
information let's look into some more
advantages and
disadvantages ethernet is suitable for
maintaining the data quality of the
information being
transmitted it also provides high-speed
data transmission option for the
network for disadvantages we have the
network traffic issue is a drawback of
installing ethernet
cables troubleshooting Falls and issues
in the ethernet cable is also a
Troublesome work now let's move on to
the last heading for this topic that is
ethernet versus
internet the first difference is
connection medium for ethernet
connection physical cables are required
that means it uses wide medium for
connection whereas in case of Internet
it uses Wireless mediums such as
satellites as a connection
medium moving on the next difference
is Network
model the ethernet is available only for
a low distance connection for example L
whereas internet is available for all
the the network connection
distances be it Lan man or
van let's move on to the next difference
that is Network
control for
ethernet the complexity of the
connection medium is low due to the less
distance it uses and also provides much
efficient transmission of data over the
communication Channel whereas for
internet is a large collection of
networks and hence require large group
of administrator for
control the last difference between
ethernet and internet
is network security and reliability
ethernet connection is a secure network
from external interference and provides
data security whereas in case of
Internet it is an open type of
connection so it is more prone to have
marking attempts and less secure network
two major types of network that should
be considered basic knowledge for
someone starting out with networking LS
and vs the first variety of networks is
a local area network also known as land
it comprises of cables gateways switches
routers and additional parts that allow
these devices to connect to private
servers cloud services and other lands
via larger networks the growth of
virtualization has also spread up the
creation of virtual lands which let
Network managers divide and logically
organize Network nodes without having to
make significant modifications to the
infrastructure the computers in each
department could be conceptually linked
to the same switch in an office with
many departments be it accountancy it
support and
administration still the might be
segregated to operate separately the
benefits of a land are similar to those
of any collection of connected devices
they may access and even control one
another exchange files print to Shared
printers and utilize a single internet
connection to better understand this
logic let us take a sample
structure we can see the various
components of a local network connection
in this
picture and now we can see three
different devices a system a laptop and
a printer so you have this few devices
that need to be connected to a single
local ADM Network now to identify these
devices inside the network we need to
assign an identifier to each device
so this is where an IP address can help
an IP address is a leny string of digits
allocated to any device connected to a
network that utilizes Internet Protocol
as the communication medium it's a
digital equivalent of your house or
workplace mailing address the addresses
are divided into four sections separated
by dots each traditional base L numeral
portion represents an 8bit binary
integer which can range from 0 to
255 these four integers are expressed in
normal decimal notation and then
separated by dog however computers work
with binary numbers meaning zeros and
ones and each number in an ipv4 address
represents an 8bit binary integer which
is why none of them can be more than
255 the distribution of these IP
addresses is not just limited to land
every device which is a part of the
network will have its own IP address as
assigned by the network administrator as
seen in the picture we can now identify
each device individually by the
designated IP
addresses now the primary purpose of a
network being the ability of multiple
devices to communicate and exchange
information with each other these IP
addresses serve only half the purpose
since allotment identification of these
addresses need to be managed
automatically and On Demand if the
laptop shown on the left of the screen
wants to use the printer in the network
it needs to know which particular device
or more precisely which particular IP
address to communicate with this is
where a switch comes into to play it
takes the role of the delegation of
commands in a particular Network let's
learn more about switches in
detail a network switch joints devices
in a network such as computers printers
wireless access points and allows them
to communicate with each other by
exchanging data packets they can be both
physical Hardware devices that handle
real networks or software based virtual
devices the vast majority of network
equipment in model data networks are
switches they linkex of PCS access
points automated equipment and some iot
devices via wide connections such as
card entry systems the link the
computers and data centers that run
virtual machines or VMS as well as the
actual server and most of the storage
equipment based on the type of switches
employed they can either differentiate
between network devices using either the
IP addresses or Mac addresses which are
separate types of addresses allotted to
each Hardware device irrespective of the
network it is connected
to now that you understand the major
parts of a local area network a major
query that may come to your mind is how
can these local networks then
communicate with other networks a router
is employed at the Forefront of every
network setup to facilitate
communication between foreign networks
this router can then be used to connect
to the Internet so we can communicate
with the loved ones from the comfort of
our own homes so let's learn a little
more about
routers the router is a physical or
virtualized inter netw working equipment
that receives analy es and transmits
data packets across computer networks
the router checks a data packets
destination IP address and utilizes
headers and forwarding tables to
determine the best path to transport the
packet consider the router to be an air
traffic controller and data package to
be airplanes flying to various airports
or networks in this case each package
like each check has a unique destination
and must be steered to its destination
as effectively as possible a router
helps direct these data packets with
that intended IP addresses in the same
manner that the air traffic controller
ensures that flights arrive at their
destination without getting lost or
experiencing severe
disruptions a router employs an internal
routing table which is a collection of
Pathways to multiple Network
destinations to properly direct packets
it scans the header of a packet to
establish its destination then consults
the routing table to find the most
efficient way to their
destination the packet is subsequently
sent to the next Network along the Route
a router also has an IP address which is
often called as the network
Gateway a crucial part of a networking
setup is determining whether a
particular piece of Hardware is a part
of local network or a foreign device as
you already know specific IP addresses
exist for each device in a network be it
a local or wide area network all these
IP addresses must belong to a particular
range of addresses which are often known
as the subnet or sub Network and which
help determine the overall range of a
local area
network for example the IP addresses
that can be seen on the screen right now
belong to a subnet that is
255.255.0.0
the first two flags denote fixed values
that must be present in every single IP
address of every single device in this
particular Network in our case the
192.168 is the consistent factor in
every single IP address shown on the
scre screen this implies that if the
devices can connect to a piece of
equipment with an IP address and it
starts from 1
192.168 that device will most likely be
in the same local area network the last
two places are the free ranges in this
example which means they can be any
number less than 255 further helping the
router and switch differentiate between
multiple IP addresses in a
network with that being said we can now
take a look at how wide area networks
work a wide area network Network or van
is in its most basic form a collection
of local area networks or any other
networks that interact with one another
y network is essentially a network of
networks with internet serving as the
world's biggest
one however when a router communicates
with devices outside a local network it
tends to master the internally allocated
IP addresses and uses a single public IP
address for all the devices this process
is called Network address translation or
n IP allocation a network address
translation is a method of translating
one IP address to another while these
packets are in transit through a router
this improves security and reduces the
number of IP addresses required by a
company once a router rece some
particular information that must be
transmitted to a local device in the
network it checks the internal routing
tables to determine the correct internal
IP address and the currect destination
to send the externally received data to
but let's say a device on the external
network or a wide Network wants to
communicate directly with a device from
the local network this cannot be allowed
since this can be a very big security
risk for devices in a secure
environment all of this entry and exit
rule creation and handling can be taken
care of by a
firewall a firewall is a type of network
security device that analyzes the
incoming and outgoing networking traffic
and allows or denies data package
depending on a set of security rules
its objective is to provide a barrier
between your local network and external
traffic such as the internet the most
common sort of firewall which are packet
filtering firewalls check packets and
prevent them from getting through if
they do not meet an established security
rule set this sort of firewall examines
the packet's destination and Source IP
addresses if the packet fits an allowed
rule on the firewall they are permitted
to access the
network but let's say we as users want
to allow external requests to reach
individual computers or devices on our
local network there are two ways to
facilitate this Behavior the first way
to go through this step is by using a
DMZ which stands for a demilitarized
zone instead of communicating directly
with the local network device the
external data is sent to the router
instead the router will have created a
DMZ sub network with only those devices
added to it that require the external
information to reach them on to once the
data is received by the router it passes
it on to the DM subet and subsequently
to all the devices which are a part of
that
subnet however since the external data
can reach devices in a network without
any firewall checks if they are part of
the DMZ subnet the security risks
associated with this method are very
large compared to the second variant
which is p
forwarding Bo forwarding is a method of
granting external devices access to
computers on private Networks it
accomplishes this by translating an
external IP address and port to an
internal IP address and Port all the
devices talk to each other and the
network Gateway using the IP addresses
and specific pools for example the TCP
IP protocol basic internet usage uses
Port 0 on every Network similarly we can
create additional file World rules to
open up certain ports for external
devices to communicate with if the
designated ports are open during
communication the firewall will allow
the external network device or server to
communicate directly with the local
network device without any hindrance
that's all we really need to know for
now about the basics of networking then
let's begin with the first heading what
is Network topology it is referred to as
an arrangement of multiple systems and
network devices interconnected to each
other through a physical medium or
logical
channel the term Network topology is
combination of two individual Network
concept first is the network part which
represents the devices or systems that
are also known as
nodes which is connected and how to
change the data within the network then
the other part is topology which
represents the connection medium between
different network devices and governs
the data flow between them moving on
let's talk about why do we apply the
concept of network topology for the the
first point it allows the users to
understand the overall model of the
network along with the number of devices
installed and their positions in the
network which provide ease of
installation of security measures and
network and helps in case of
troubleshooting cases then for the next
reason applying Network topology helps
the user to understand the communication
relationship among the different devices
and through a connection
medium this in turn helps the network
professionals to set up an optimal
Network unit for the
user next in the list we have different
types of topologies used in
networking first is the bus topology
then we have ring topology Then star
topology then tree topology and in the
end mesh topology but to understand the
concept of topology let's start by Point
too topology this is simplest form of
topology connection which consist of two
nodes connected through a connection
medium like a network
cable the nodes at the two ends of the
cable shares data information between
them where the data sharing part
represents the network and the cable
connection is the topology part with
this we have understanding of network
topology then let's begin with complex
types of tech connection connections
first is the bus topology in this
topology the connection channel is a
single cable known as the network bbone
through which all the other nodes are
connected to in this network setting the
data packets sent by the nodes are
provided with the receiver address to
avoid transmission errors the data in
this topology can travel from any
endpoint where they are termed as
terminate points advantages of bus
topology it is easy to set up due to the
simple configuration settings this
setting is also cost effective as it
requires only a network cable for the
connection in the case of Crash no the
whole network remains unaffected as it
does not have any direct connection to
the other node let's take a look at
disadvantages of bus topology in case of
troubleshooting we require the use of
special equipment to detect The Fault in
the network in in the case of multiple
data transmission the packet Collision
is the frequent occurrence damaging the
transmitted message data due to the
unavailability of network devices such
as switches repeaters Etc the loss of
data over long distances communication
is quite High then ring topology as the
name suggests the node in the network
are connected in a circular pattern
similar to a ring the data transmitted
in this connection is always in the
clockwise Direction the topology does
not have any termination point due to
its ring structure the method of data
transmission is used is known as token
passing which involves sending a token
along with the data packet to which each
of the node matches to identify the
destination node using the destination
address in the
token next advantages of ring top ology
the crash node can be easily removed
from the network the configuration
settings are not complex for setup and
materials are easily accessible the cost
of installation is low as no extra
Network device are required to the
connection moving on we have
disadvantages of ring topology in the
case of a node crash the whole system is
affected and is non accessible due to
the direct connection of each node the
transfer of data is slow due to the
Token passing method in the network
difficulty in the troubleshooting fault
in the connection leads to the crash of
the whole network now let's talk about
start topology in this topology the
networks are connected to each other
through the central Hub which can be a
computer or a server the central unit in
the connection is also known as the
server and the nodes are known as the
clients any connection between the node
has to be through the server and is one
of the most popular topology connection
next advantages of star topology in case
of a Noe crash the network as a whole
remains unaffected as each node is
connected to the server of a connection
the hardware requirement are easily
available and of low cost
troubleshooting is easy through the use
of central Hub to identify the faulty
node disadvantages in case of a server
failure the whole network is shut down
as all nodes are interconnected through
the server the connection configuration
is complex due to the pattern of the
typology next up tree topology this
topology is a combination of tar and bus
topology the note Connection in the
topology follows hechal pattern with the
topmost node as a root and the branching
node as a child node the sharing of data
is from the root node to the child node
pattern next up advantages of tree
installation of a new network group is
easy due to the root child configuration
of the network in case of a node fault
or crash the whole network is not
affected by the error this makes it
easier to troubleshoot the issue next up
disadvantages in case of a server crash
in any of the star connection groups the
whole network is affected due to the
complex setting of The topology
installing security points is difficult
in the network
configuring and troubleshooting internal
issues is quite complex due to this
typology next up Mash topology as the
name suggest this topology is a
connection of interconnected system
connected to each other in no particular
order no installation of network devices
such as switch or hubs this topology
pattern can be divided into two forms
first is full Mash topology in this
connection all the nodes are connected
to each other other in the network then
we have partial mesh topology where all
of the nodes are connected to each other
available in the network let's talk
about the advantages of mesh topology in
case of node damage the whole network
does not suffer from the fault due to
the interconnected patterns of the
connection the transmission of data is
very high in the network next up
disadvantages the cost of installation
is high due to the requirement of
multiple cables and nodes for the
network to function efficiently the
management of the network becomes
complex due to the large number of
interconnection in the network due to
the absence of repeater or a switch the
data signal loss during the transmission
is very high now let's take a look at
how to choose best topology for our
network configuration first up cost the
installation cost is one of the biggest
factor that affect the type of topology
configuration we choose from our Network
as the cost of installing cables routers
switches and other network connections
is low then we have easy installation
installing the hardware devices
efficiently and precisely is also one of
the factors that affect our choice of
network topology moving on we have
flexibility the ability of the topology
to include new network nodes after
installation and ease of troubleshooting
refers to the flexibility of topology in
the hand we have reliable security it is
important that the topology installed
allows us to introduce proper security
points in the network and leading the
fewer crash CES by referring the above
factors we can decide the best topology
for our Network to better understand the
OSI model let's take a look at a
scenario assuming we have two different
systems with different operating system
installed in
them and there's a communication Channel
between them over which the data is
shared but sometimes during transmission
of data it faces some problems these
errors often arise due to the different
operating system installed in the system
or due to a network problem during a
transmission but to overcome such
situations The OSI model structure is
used using the OSI model structure we
can make the transmission of data over
the communication Channel error
free let's take a look at the definition
for the USI
model The OSI model stands for Open
System interconnection model or a
specifically designed set of protocols
and standards that governs the modeling
and conversion of the data for proper
transmission over the network
channels the usosm model is based on the
layer structure where it consists of
seven different layers
where each layer has different set of
protocols that are to be applied on the
data during the transmission over the
network
channel let's take a look at the
different layers of the OSI
model The OSI model consists of seven
different layers which perform specific
functions and apply different protocols
at different layers to maintain the
quality and prevent the data from
getting corrupted when it is transmitted
over the communication
Channel let's take a look at each of
them the first layer is known as the
application layer which is a topmost
layer then we have the presentation
layer session layer transport layer
Network layer data link layer and
physical layer which is the last layer
of the ASI
model the upper four layers in the ASI
model represents the host layers that is
they interact with the application
related issues when the data is
transmitted over the communication
Channel whereas the lower layers are
termed as Network L they specifically
deal with the transmission related steps
for the data over the network
jannel let's take a look about some
information in regards to the
layers now let's take a look at the
function and the data format that is
handled by each of the layers during the
transmission of data
the first layer is the application layer
which interacts as a Gateway for the
host data and network applications and
handles the data
format then we have the presentation
layer which handles the initial step
towards the conversation of data for
transfer it also handles the data
format then we have the session layer
session layer establishes a connection
between the network devices for the data
transfer then we have the transport
layer which oversees the data that is
transferred without any error and is in
the same pattern needed by the
destination system the data format
handled by this layer is segment
format next we have the network layer
which determines the part for the data
transfer it handles packet related
data then we have the data link layer
which performs the task of connecting
the physical nodes for the transfer of
data it handles Frame data and in the
end we have the physical layer which is
used to transfer the raw bits that is in
terms of ones and zeros over the
physical
mode now that we are clear about
different layers that are present in the
USI model and some information regarding
them let's take a look at each of the
layers in detail we'll start with top to
bottom that is the application layer
will be the layer that will be starting
with let's take a
look the topmost layer in the OSI model
is the application layer which acts as
an interface between the user and the
applications that are being accessed
which can be Internet Explorer Chrome or
any email client it also handles
different protocols that are needed for
the data transmission over the network
channel which can be given as hypertext
transfer protocol the HTTP protocol and
the SMTP protocol which is the simple
maale transfer protocols now let's move
on to the next layer the next layer is
known as the presentation layer the
presentation layer is responsible for
performing conversion task over the data
that is received from the application
lay the conversion of data is done in
accordance to the required
format it also performs encryption over
the converted data so as to prevent it
from getting hacked by cyber criminals
or
hackers the compression of the encrypted
data is also performed by the
presentation layer so that it can be
passed on to the session
layer the next layer in the OSI model is
known as the session layer in this layer
the communication Channel between two
different devices is established the
network devices are individually known
as
session the data that is transferred is
to be done over these session
channels the layer that is the session
layer establishes and terminates these
sessions in case of an error or some
other unforeseen
event this layer is also responsible for
authentication checks regarding the data
that is is mean transfer and also
provides data recovery options in case
an error occurs over the communication
Channel model L let's take up a question
the question is what is the main action
that takes place at the presentation lay
and the options are First Option data
segmentation second option encryption of
data third option framing of data and
the fourth option bit conversion of data
you can provide your answers in the
comment section below let's move on with
the next
layer the next layer in the ASM model is
known as the transport layer the main
task performed by this layer is to break
the data that is received from the
session layer into different
segments these segments comprises of
protocols which are UDP protocol and TCP
protocol along with the data that is
segmented from the the received
data then the segmented data along with
the UDP and TCP identification it
transferred over to the transmission
Channel where then it's further
transferred to the network devices that
requested for the
data this layer also performs a very
crucial part which is the flow control
let's understand flow control over the
network channel through a small
example in this example the server has a
capacity to send 50 MVPs of data at once
whereas the receiver side has a capacity
for 10
MVPs when the data is transferred from
the server to the client it transfers 50
MVPs but it is impossible to transfer
all this data at once due to the lower
capacity on the client site which is why
the flow control changes is required
which is provided to the server site by
the transport
layer now let's move on to the network
layer which is the third layer from the
botton in the OSI
model this layer is responsible for
breaking down these segments into Data
packets by adding IP address to them
that is received from the transport
layer these data packets are then
further transmitted over to the best
possible route to the destination system
which are governed by the internet
protocols including IP and IPv6
protocols for example if we have a data
that is to be transferred to the network
device 2 we choose the best option that
is the route to be transferred over to
that Network
device now let's move on to the next
layer in the OSI model which is a data
link
layer this layer is responsible for
maintaining and terminating the
established connection between the
devices over the
network the MAC address in this layer is
added to the data packets which are
collectively known as data frames these
data frames are then further transmitted
over to the physical
Network these are divided into two
different
sublayers medium access control that is
Mac which controls the established
connection device and the second sub
layer is logic link control layer LLC
which identifies the address and provide
flow control for the
data this data frame as earlier told is
transferred over to the physical
L now let's take a look at another
question to brush up whatever we learned
so far the question is which layer
includes the max sub layer in the OSI
model option one application layer
option two session layer option three
data link lay option four transport lay
you can give your answers in the comment
section
below let's move on to the last layer in
the OSI model which is a physical
layer this layer is responsible and
provides the physical medium over which
the data frame is transferred but the
transfer data is converted into bits
before it's
transferred the transmission of data is
covered by different protocols that are
embed in the physical lay the
transmission of ones and zeros format
data is done it also responsible for
maintaining the data quality by applying
different necessary protocols and
maintaining the bit rate throughout the
transfer of data whether it be wired
medium or Wireless medium firstly we'll
understand what exactly is the model the
tcpip model is a method of sharing data
and information over the Communication
channel where the data has to go through
each of the four layer structure of the
network
model where it also performs tasks such
as remodeling of data efficient
transmission and air related issues each
layer has dedicated protocols that they
enact on the transmission
data now let's continue with the
protocols that are used in the TCP I
model to understand the protocols that
are used in the tcpip model we'll
compare it with the OSI model and if you
want to know more about the OSI model
you can visit our video on the simply
learn Channel let's
begin the topmost three layers of the
OSI model which are application layer
presentation layer and session layer
collectively refers to the application
layer in the tcpip model where they use
protocols such as FTP file transfer
protocol http hypertext transfer
protocol T length and SMTP which is
simple male transfer
protocol then we have the transport
layer from osm model which refers to the
transport layer in the tcpip model where
they apply protocols such as TCP
transmission control protocol and UDP
user datagram protocol moving on we have
Network layer from The OSI model which
refers to the internet layer in the
tcpip model
which apply protocols such as IP
Internet Protocol icmp internet control
message protocol and
ARP address resolution
protocol then we have data link layer
and physical layer from the USI model
which refer to the network access layer
in the tcpip
model this layer doesn't exactly apply
any protocol but are connected through
physical medium which includes ethernet
by Wii and
cables now that we are completed with
the protocols regarding tcpip model
let's take a look at the layers in
detail the tcv IP network model consists
of different layers where the original
model consists of four different layers
which are application layer transport
layer internet layer and network access
layer then we have the updated model
which consists of layer applic a layer
transport layer internet layer data link
layer and physical layer let's take a
look at the layers in
detail the first layer that we are going
to know about is the application layer
application layer this layer acts as an
interface between the application and
programs that require the tcpip model
for communication including tasks
performed by the layer such as data
represent presentation for the software
application that are executed by the
user and then forward it to the
transport
lay the protocols supplied by this
layers
are HTTP hypertex transfer protocol
which is used to access information
available on the internet then we have
SMTP simple mail transfer protocol which
is used to access email related
task moving forward we have the
transport layer this layer is
responsible for establishing connection
between the sender and the receiver
device this layer performed the task of
dividing the data from the application
laay into packets where they are used to
create sequences which are then
transferred over to the destination
device it also performs the task of
maintaining the data that is to be
transmitted without error and controls
the data flow rate the protocols that
are applied in the transport layer are
TCP transmission control protocol which
is responsible for transmission of
segments over the communication
Channel then we have UDP user datagram
protocol which is responsible for
identifying error in the data that is to
be transmitted over the communication
Channel moving forward the next layer is
the internet
layer this layer is responsible for the
transmission of data over the network
channel
that is they provide a proper route for
the packets to be transferred over the
communication
channel the protocols that are applied
by this internet layer are IP protocol
which is the Internet Protocol this
protocol assigns a unique address to a
physical system so that it can be
identified on the
internet then we have
ARP address resolution protocol this
protocol is used to find the physical
address of the system using the Internet
Protocol
address in the end we have the network
access layer this layer is a combination
of data link layer and physical layer
from the USI model where it is
responsible for maintaining the task of
sending and receiving data in draw
bits the raw bits are transferred from
the cender site to the receiver side in
the format of binary digit which are
zeros and
ones let's move on with the advantages
of using the TCP IP
model the TCP IP model assigns an IP
address to each of the system that is
available on the network channel so that
they can be identified on the internet
then they are also responsible for
enacting different protocols on the data
that is to be transmitted over the
Communication channel the TCP IP model
also enables the user and the system to
access different format of data over the
communication
Channel now let's take a look at the
last topic for this session which is the
OSI model versus a tcpip
model on comparing both of the network
models we get the OSI model consists of
seven different layers whereas the tcpi
model comprises of four different layers
The OSI model has separate session layer
presentation layer whereas the tcpip
model comprises of a single application
layer the transport layer in the OSI
model provides packet delivery
protocols but in the tcpip model
transport layer does not provide any
such
protocols The OSI model is implemented
during network communication but in case
of tcpip model model it is used as a
reference model for the network
channel if you are someone who is
interested in building a career in cyber
security or a networking professional by
graduating from the best universities or
a professional who elicits to switch
careers with networking by learning from
the experts then try giving a short to
Simply learns postgraduate program in
cyber security with modules from MIT
schwarzman College of Engineering the
course link is mentioned in the
description box below that will navigate
you to the course page where you can
find a complete overview of the program
being offered introduction to network
protocol a network protocol is like a
set of rules that govern how devices in
a network communicate with each other
these rules are like instructions that
specify how data should be sent received
and understood by the devices Network
Protocols are formalized requirements
and plans that consist of rules and
procedures that describe how devices
should interact with each other over a
network they provide a communication
system to exchange information using
various physical means means such as
cables or wireless connections just like
humans follow certain protocols when
they interact with each other network
protocols Define a specific steps and
guidelines for devices to follow these
rules ensure that information is sent
and received correctly and that all
devices involved understand each other
in essence Network Protocols are a way
for devices to speak the same language
and follow a common set of guidelines so
that they can successfully share
information and work together
effectively now let's understand the
need of network protocols all right so
let me explain this to you in simple
terms Network Protocols are like
guidelines that devices follow when they
communicate with each other over a
network these Protocols are needed for
several reasons firstly Network
protocols ensure that devices understand
each other imagine if you and your
friend were speaking different languages
and had no way to understand each other
communication would be impossible
similarly devices from different
manufacturers and with different
functions need a Common Language or
protocol to understand each other
signals and data secondly Network
protocols ensure that data is
transmitted reliably when you send a
message or a browser a website you want
to make sure that the information
reaches its destination accurately and
without errors Network protocols help in
breaking down data into smaller packets
sending them across the network and
reassembling them correctly at the
receiving end thirdly Network protocols
provide security they include measures
to protect data from authorized access
and ensure that sensitive information
remains confidential this is
particularly important when you make
online transactions or share personal
information over the Internet lastly
Network protocols allow for
interoperability this means that devices
from different manufacturers and with
different functions can work together
seamlessly for example your computer can
connect to a printer and your smartphone
can access a Wi-Fi network because they
follow the same protocols so these were
some of the needs of Network protocols
now before understanding the types of
network protocols we must understand
about ethernet so ethernet is a type of
network protocol that help devices
connect and communicate with each other
in a local area network landan it is
like a highway that allows data to
travel between devices such as computers
printers and routers ethernet uses a set
of rules and procedures to transmit data
in the form of packets these packets are
like small packages of information that
are sent from one device to another
ethernet and show that these packets are
delivered to the right destination and
in the correct order think of ethernet
as the road system that connects all the
devices in a network it ensures that
data can flow smoothly between devices
enabling them to share information and
work together efficiently now let's have
a look at the types of network protocols
here we will cover some of the types of
network protocols we'll start with the
first one which is TCP that is
transmission control protocol TCP is a
network protocol that ensures reliab an
order delivery of data between devices
it breaks down data into smaller packets
sends them across the network and
ensures that they are reassembled
correctly at the receiving end TCP also
handles error detection and
retransmission if any packets are lost
or corrupted during transmission so this
was about TCP or transmission control
protocol now second is IP that is
Internet Protocol IP is another Network
protocol that handles the addressing and
routing of packets across the internet
it assigns unique IP addresses to
devices and determines how data is sent
from The Source device to the
destination device IP ensures that the
data packets reach the right destination
by routing them through various network
devices like routers third is UDP or
user datagram protocol UDP is a network
protocol that provides a faster but less
reliable method of data transmission
compared to TCP it does not establish a
connection or guarantee packet delivery
or order you UDP is commonly used for
time sensitive applications like video
streaming or online gaming where a small
amount of data loss is acceptable next
is poop that is post office protocol PO
is a network protocol used for
retrieving emails from a mail server to
a client device it allows users to
download emails from the server onto
their device and manage them locally
poop is typically used by email clients
like Outlook or thunderboard next we
have is SMTP or simple mail transfer
protocol SMTP is a network protocol used
for sending emails from a client device
to a mail server it handles the
transmission of email messages and
ensure that they are delivered to the
appropriate recipient's mail server SMTP
is responsible for the reliable transfer
of email across different mail servers
so this was about simple mail transfer
protocol now let's understand the sixth
one which is file transfer protocol or
FTP FTP is a network protocol used for
transferring files between devices over
a network it provides a standard method
for uploading and downloading files to
and from a remote server FTP allows
users to navigate directories transfer
files and manage file permissions now
coming to the next which is hyper text
transfer protocol secure that is
https https a secure version of HTTP
that provides encryption and
authentication it ensures that the data
transmitted between a web browser and a
web server is encrypted and protected
from unauthorized access https is
commonly used for secure online
transactions sensitive data transfers
and protecting users privacy so these
were some of the types of network
protocols so basically Network protocols
play a crucial role in enabling
communication and data transfer across
various computer networks we have
explored several types of network
protocols each serving specific purpose
and operating at different layers of
networking model ip4
addresses
the first version of an IP address to be
developed was based on 32-bit B format
that counts roughly around 2 to the^ 32
bits of total IP addresses in ipb4
format which was sufficient at the
initial phase of network requirement but
is somewhat lacking according to the
current advancement in the Network
Technology the addresses in this IP
ranges from 0 to 225 in terms of zeros
and ones with four octads where each of
them is separated by a
period this is an example for an ipv4 IP
address where the first three parts
represent the network ID and the last
part represents the host
ID using the ipv4 address as our
reference we can identify ipb4 addresses
from ipb 6
addresses now now let's move on to the
next topic that is IP
classes IP classes are designed to allow
easy and efficient assignment of IP
addresses to a network depending on
class size we have five different IP
classes in a network that are named as a
b c and
d for the first part we have class A
that accommodates network with a large
number of network host where the first
bit in the octet is always zero with
number value ranging from 0 to
127 then we have class P which can
fulfill the requirement for a moderate
number of network host the lead bit is 1
and zero and network ID ranges from 128
to
191 then we have class C which can
allocate an IP address for Low number of
network host where the first three bits
of the network ID is one 1 1 and 0
ranging from 192 to
223 through the above three classes that
is Class A B and C we can easily
identify and assign addresses to a
network
host moving on we have class D where it
is used for
multicasting that means it is used to
send multiple signals at the same time
from a single host for example using
video stream in where the lead bit is
111 and Zer with network ID ranges from
224 to
239 and then we have class E where the
IP bits for this is reserved for
research purpose only where the IP
addresses ranges from 240 to
255 moving on let's take a look at some
of the features for ipv4 version
addresses where the first is
the memory required for storing ipv4
version addresses in a system is very
low then we have ip4 version addresses
apply connectionless protocol for
sharing data and providing the best
effort in
delivery moving on we have stacking
option for ipb4 addresses that means in
ipv4 version it allows to create a
multiple network over a single host
which allows different host to connect
to
it moving on we have ip4 version
addresses being the earliest IP design
are applicable to most of the network
devices and system for connecting to the
internet so it is supported by many
devices then we have IPv6 addresses
let's take a
look with the increase in the need for
an IP address the ip4 version addresses
are somewhat unable to complete the
requirements of the network host so the
need for ipb4 version arose which is
based on 128bit address size which is
sufficient for a very long time that is
approximately 320 unilan IP addresses in
version
6 this type of IP version is designed of
four hexadecimal digit and eight sets
with each block containing 16
separated by a
colon moving on let's take a look at
some of the features for ipv 6 version
addresses where the first is ipv version
6 addresses provides an integrated
security protocol for the network that
is Internet Protocol security IP
SEC then we have it allows its
application to extend in various
Services according to the need of the
network it also allows address
configuration through stateful that uses
DHCP server for network settings and
stateless that applies autoconfiguration
settings IPv6 addresses also allows some
methods to convert ipv4 addresses to
IPv6 addresses which is according to the
requirement of the host or the
network
moving on let's take a look at the
differences between ipv4 version
addresses and IPv6 version addresses
this heading would allow us to choose a
best IP address that we can decide for a
network let's take a look at the first
difference that is address and
performance in accordance to the address
size ibv 4 version is composed of 32-bit
address length and is the fourth version
version of the Internet
Protocol for ibv 6 we have the address
size is 128bit long and is the latest
version of the Internet
Protocol the second difference is on the
basis of address field type IPv6
addresses are based on numeric data with
four Fields each separated by a
period whereas for IPv6 addresses are
based on Alpha numeric type data with
eight Fields each separated by a
colon the next difference is based on
address
configuration in ipv 4 version addresses
a manual setting for the network is
required along with the dhcb
configuration settings whereas in case
of IPv6 version addresses the network
setting is based in accordance to the
systems requirement and it also supports
Auto configur configuration setting for
the
system moving on we have the number of
addresses in each
IP in case of ipb4 the total number of
addresses are nearly 4 billion addresses
whereas in case of ip6 version we have
320 unilan
addresses now let's take up a quiz to
understand what we did so far and the
question question is identify the
correct form of ipv4 version address in
the given options and the options
are you can give your answers in the
comment section
below let's move on to the next
difference that is address security and
functioning ipb4 version addresses do
not provide any security function for
the network whereas in case of ip6
addresses integrated Internet Security
protocol that it's IPC is responsible
for the security of the
network the next difference is
encryption and authentication
settings ipv4 version does not provide
any encryption or authentication
services for the
network IPv6 addresses do provide
mandatory encryption and authentication
services for its
addresses moving on we have address
routing and
performance ipv4 version follows routing
protocol that is Rip for network
configuration and is preferred over IPv6
version and in case of
IPv6 it does not follow any routing
protocols and it uses static roots for
Network
functioning now that we are completed
with the differences between IPv6 and
ipv4 we can easily identify the IP P
address we want to choose for a
network let's take a look at Network
sniffing to access the network related
information between devices to gain
profit or use the hack data for illegal
purpose is known as Network sniffing
this is a process where a hacker or a
misses programmer spy into the network
devices of our system they can access
different websites that we visit often
or see our Network habit
let's take a look at different tools
that are suitable for sniffing
purpose Network sniffing tools are
softwares that are available on the
internet that can be used to sniff into
the network let's take a look at some of
the famous Network Tools first one is
AIC this is a networking sniffing tool
which has specialization in intelligent
analysis for Network
packets next is v shark this soft
software tool is best to look into
protocol related data packets that are
often transmitted over the
network and lastly we have solar wi
Network packet sniffer where the
performance of this sniffing tool is
best where the Performance Management is
to be looked
into let's take a look at the Y shark
sniffing tool this is an open-source
Network sniffing software which is
specifically designed to attack data
Pockets during the transmission over the
network this type of software uses
different color combinations to
represent different packets and
protocols let's take a look at some of
the uses for the sniffing software the
first uses it is used to analyze Network
packets whereas it can also be used to
troubleshoot different network issues
which are often used by different
Engineers to test whether the software
or network device is acceptible to an
attack
and lastly it is also used to check
malicious and hacking possibilities on
the network now that we are completed
with the briefing for the software that
is known as Yar let's take a look at the
actual demo how exactly Network sniffing
is done you can directly access the vhar
software
website where you can find the download
option and download the most suitable
version for your laptop or computer
device
after downloading the software when you
install
it you'll get something like
this as we can see these connections are
the connections that are connected to my
laptop right
now and the difference in the graph that
we can see over year represent the
traffic on the network that is
present to much better understand what
exactly is going on the network we can
access one of them let's access the
Wi-Fi network on my
laptop after accessing the network we
can see some packet settings like
this these represents the packet
transaction that has been made on my
network through the internet
and this is how a hacker or a cyber
criminal knows how exactly we use a
network
services this part of the V shck
represents different detailed
information about the transaction that
has been
made and the last section represents
some raw data or Garbage
data but how exactly a hacker use all
this jumble data and hack into a system
well to clarify this there's an option
that can be used that is known as
display filter on the wihar software if
you want to search for a specific
protocol for example TCP we can write
TCP in the search filter and
search and now as we can see we only get
the protocols that are related to
TCP this is how we can differentiate
different protocols and access some of
them to gain knowledge about what exact
is going on the
network let's try accessing some other
protocol now for example
DNS and as we can see only the protocol
and the data packet that is related to
DNS protocol is visible to
us to further enhance the display filter
let's try accessing a different page on
the web browser for
example see simply
learn.com when we access the simplylearn
website we can see the professional
courses that are available but let's
take a look at the changes that has been
made on the Y
shark to know this let's write TCP and a
keyword included contains and one more
thing to include over here is during the
display filter if you write something
that is related to the software it will
represent in a green color like this but
if you write some error related keywords
like this it will represent in the red
let's continue with the search
setting including the contains keyword
and
writing simply
learn and entering now as we can see
these two related data packets represent
the simply learn website that we access
just now where the source destination IP
address represent my system address
whereas the destination that is
13.24 21. 74 represent the simply learns
IP address let's take a
look and in the garbage area or the raw
data we can take a look simply learn
website to see some more details
regarding the same you can access the
transport layer
security and the transmission control
protocol where we can see the source
Port the destination Port which is
always
443 as well as the
flag and the time stamp for the
same this is how hackers get the data
about a network settings but if we want
to search for more data related to
Simply learn website that we visited
just now there's an another filter that
we can use
for example using ip.
addr space equal equal and writing the
IP address for the website simply learn
that is 13.22
21. 74 and when we press enter we get
all the related data for the simply
learn
website and this is how we can see the
related data
to much further enhance our display
settings let's try in another
example access your internet
browser and access some other website
for
example do for example the State
University and access the alabad State
University and some other part in net
for example the university State
PDF let's see the changes in our V shock
settings and try using
HTTP when we write this we get the data
that is related to the HTTP but what is
the use for the
same when you access this and right
click on the same and choose the option
follow and HTTP
stream and over here we can take a look
at the poost that is the website that we
just
visited now imagine if we were a hacker
and we knew all this we can access any
website that our user
visited and we can hack into his system
through the
website guys but the point that has to
be noted over here is if we use the
network sniffing tool V Shar or some
other tool that is available on the
internet for research purpose or
experimental use that's fine but we
shouldn't use all these softwares for
any malicious activity CU that is
illegal now some of the options that we
can see are the red box this action is
used if you want to stop the traffic
connection that means if you press this
option and clear this and press enter
this shows that the network settings has
stopped receiving any traffic that is
available on the network but if we want
to access them again we can choose this
blue fin
option continue without saving and the
software
against start recording the websites or
the data packets that are available on
the
network now let's take a look at an
example as we all know we often visit
different websites and there are some
cases we often see when the Chrome
represent a non-secure
option that represents that the website
is unprotected against network attack
for example we can access a experimental
website this is a website that allows us
to access the non-secure part of a
website if we write for username as
admin
1213 and for password as simply
learn and
login as this is an experimental website
it says it's sorry and the login has
failed let's see the changes in a y
shark
software now as we already did earlier
here if we want to access a specific
website we should write
TCP contains and the keyword of the
website that
was
admin through this we can see this was
the website that we visited just
now but if we want to access the actual
important data that was the password
that we typed we can use this option and
over here we can see the simply learn
which was encrypted earlier in the
website this is how a hacker or a cyber
criminal use different sniffing
softwares and gain data about different
users and with this we have reached the
end of the session what is
subnetting the process of subnetting is
to divide the network into smaller
Network Parts this allow the system to
have better connectivity in the system
it also increases the security measures
for the network against hacking attempts
and also maintains an efficient flow of
network
traffic the smaller divided units of the
network are known as subn networks
taking an example of an IP address with
sl24 representing the subnet mask can be
divided into two subn networks of sl25
subnet mask which can further be divided
into smaller sub
Networks
now that we understand what is
subnetting let's move on to class
addresses and subnet
mask firstly let's begin with class
addresses to better understand the
submitting process we need some
information regarding different classes
used in IP address where the first class
is Class A with a range of 0 to 127
Network bits as
sl8 then we have class P with the range
of 128 to 191
with network bits as 16 and lastly we
have class C with network range of 192
to
223 with network bits as
24 the network bits representing each
class are very important when making
subnets of a particular IP address let's
see how they do
so for this we'll be representing each
class in binary format for class A we
have 1 for 8 Bits for class B 16 bits
and Class C 24
bits moving on we will see what exactly
is the subnet mask to better Define the
sub networks in the system we require
the use of a subnet mask that is the
subnet mask is a way to differentiate
between the portion of an IP address
that represents the network address ID
and the host network
ID
in this let's see the default subnet
mask for each of the class for class A
we have 255.0.0.0
for class P we have
255.255.0.0
whereas for Class C we have
255.255.255.0 to better understand this
let's take a look at the classes
individually the network ID part is the
one that represents the binary digit 1
whereas host ID represents binary digit
zero that means for class A we have
eight bits as network ID and the
remaining bits as host
ID by looking at the host ID we can see
that the network addresses that are
available for the host is the largest in
the class
A whereas for class P we have 16 bits
for network ID and the remaining for
host ID
where we can see the remaining part for
the host ID is lesser than Class A that
means Class B can assign Network IDs for
a medium level
company and lastly for Class C we have
24 bits as network ID and the remaining
for host ID from this we can see that
the host ID used for Class C is the
lowest that means only smaller division
companies can use Class
C moving on let let's take a look at the
characteristics of the subnetting
process first is the network ID which
represent the first IP address in each
subnet
block then we have broadcast ID which
indicates the last IP address of the sub
Network block moving on we have first
host ID which is the immediate first IP
address after the network ID then we
have last host ID as the name suggest it
defines the IP address before the
broadcast
ID continuing we have next network ID
this defines the network ID of the next
subnet
block then we have the total number of
IP
addresses in the sub Network block and
lastly we have subnet mask or CER which
represents the network ID and the host
ID part in an IP address to better
understand all the attributes of the
subnetting let's take a look at an
example in this example we are assuming
an IP address
192.168.0 pointx with a subnet mask of
24 for this IP address we have divided
it into four parts that represent
sl25
27/27 and last part a
sl26 now let's find out the details that
means the attributes for the sub Network
/25 the first attribute is the number of
IP
addresses going by the table we have 0
to 256 addresses in a single block but
in this sl25 represent only 0 to 128
that means the total number of addresses
in /25 subnet block is 128
moving on we'll find out subnet mask or
CER that is the default subnet mask of
Class C which I've taken reference from
the subnet table which was explained in
the earlier
slide which is
255.255.255.192 in our case it is
192.168.0.0 then we have broadcast ID
which is the last IP address in any sub
Network Block in our case it is
192.168.0.1
127 moving on the network ID and the
broadcast ID addresses cannot be
assigned to any network device in the
network because the network ID is used
to identify the sub Network Block in a
network along with broadcast ID which is
used to communicate with any of the host
that is connected to the subn network
block that also means that the total
number of usable network ID addresses in
a network blog is total number of IP
addresses minus 2 that represents
network ID and broadcast ID that would
be 128 minus 2 and we get the value
126 which represents the total number of
IP addresses that are
usable moving on the next attribute is
first host
ID that means the first ID after the
network ID which is
192.168.0.1 then we have the last host
ID which is
192.168.0.1 126 which is just before the
broadcast
ID and lastly the next network ID which
is
192.168.0.1
128 now that we are clear about all the
characteristics of our subn Network how
about a practice round for everyone to
find all the characteristics for the sub
Network block sl27 subnet
mask you can give your answers in the
comment section
let's move on to the benefits of using
subnetting where the first benefit is
enhance Network efficiency through the
use of applications of subnetting we can
share data to not only a specific
portion of the network model rather than
broadcasting to the whole network
causing unnecessary traffic in the
channel as shown in the
example over here we see four different
hosts and if we want to share a specific
data to only two of the host we can
subnet them into specific Parts through
this the router will only send data to
the specific portion of a sub Network
rather than broadcasting to the whole
network channel this will prevent
Network
traffic moving on the other benefit of
using subnetting process is network
security subing also provides protection
to an extent against any hacking
attempts made on the network model due
to the complexity of the sub networks as
presented in the
example during the hacking attempt if we
can identify how the virus attacks the
network model we can prevent it from
attacking all the sub networks by
compromising a single or two of them and
preventing the remaining sub
networks let's move on to the drawbacks
of using subnetting process
the very first drawback of using the
subnetting process is it makes the
network model much more complex which in
turns affects the maintenance and
efficiency then we have the unused IP
addresses which are left over from
applying the network model in a sub
Network process and lastly we have the
low efficiency use of Hardware devices
if the hardware devices such as router
or switches used are of low efficiency
the performance of the sub Network water
switching
techniques switching techniques are
network techniques responsible for
overseeing the transmission of data over
different communication channels they
are also responsible for choosing the
best route for data
transfer next we will look into why to
apply these switching
techniques using the switching
techniques we can choose the best and
the most efficient route for data
transfer in the
network for example if we want to send
some data from node a to node B we can
do so by moving from node a to a switch
then node D then to note B but doesn't
this seems like too long this is where
the switching techniques plays its role
using the switching Technique we can
choose the smallest and the most
efficient way that is no day switch then
to the node
B next we will look into different types
of switching
techniques switching techniques can be
divided into three primary types the
first is circuit
switching that requires a predestined
path for data transmission then we have
message switching which integrates the
destination address with the data for
transmission
and in the end we have packet
switching that divides its message into
smaller units known as
packets packet switching can further be
divided into two different types that
are virtual switching and datagram
switching now let's look into some
details regarding each of the
types on the first note we have circuit
switching in circuit switching for data
transmission to a
a pre-established path is required
between the sender and the receiver node
for
example assume that we call someone then
this request is sent over to the network
switches and the root is to be
established for the signal to pass
through after the system assigns a root
for the signal to pass through then the
receiver receives the call from the
caller side this is how it
works now let's look into some points to
remember about circuit
switching for circuit switching we
require a dedicated Channel established
between the source and the destination
node for the network to pass
through the data transmission can take
place only after the path is established
and the last point to remember is other
than the sender and the destination node
no node can inter with the transmission
of data to the established
route let's look at some advantages and
disadvantages of applying circuit
switching in a
network for first one we have
advantages data transmission in circuit
switching is sure to be established due
to the predestined
path circuit switching is preferred for
long and continuous transmission of data
due to the pre lished path
throughout then let's look into some
disadvantages the time required to
establish the connection is quite long
due to the time required to establish a
path also due to the continuous
transmission of data in circuit
switching more bandwidth is required for
maintaining the
connection let's move on with message
switching in message switching no
predestined path is established between
the sender and the destination Noe in
the
message this technique integrates the
destination address into the data
transmitted and is shared over the
network let's look into the setup to
better understand the working of message
switching for First Step the center node
integrates the destination address into
the
message then the whole message is
transmitted to the switching node in the
network where it gets stored for the
next
transmission and similarly like the
Second Step this transmission of data is
done over the whole network and finally
through the destination address in the
data it reaches the receiver
node this is how the message switching
Works let's take a look at some points
to remember about message switch
in in message switching no predestined
path is
established it uses Dynamic routing as
the message is transmitted through the
communication channel in real
time the each node in network switching
stores the data unless it is transferred
over to the next switch
node let's take a look at some
advantages and disadvantages of a plan
method
switching to begin with let's take a
look at the
advantages the size of the data that can
be transmitted over message switching is
variable in message switching the use of
bandwidth is done in an efficient
manner now let's look into some
disadvantages for message switching the
nodes that are known as the switch node
is to be provided with sufficient
storage
memory there's a delay in reaching the
destination due to the message technique
that is the message has to stop at each
of the switch node before it is
transferred over to the destination
node now let's look into the last
switching technique that is packet
switching in packet switching the
message is broken into smaller data
units known as packets these packets are
appended with relevant Network details
for the transmission over the network
let's look into the working of packet
switching we know that in packet
switching the data is broken into
smaller units packets which each packet
is given a sequence number for
identification these packets are
integrated with required sender and
receiver address and switching method to
choose the smallest route to reach the
destination
node these pack ETS are then recombined
at the destination node in the correct
sequence
order now let's look into some points to
remember for packet
switching for packet switching all the
data packets that are provided with
unique number for identification at the
receiver end that
is 1 2 3 and four in the previous
example we just
used
packet switching chooses the most
shortest path possible for the data to
reach the destination
end in case we have unreached packet or
some unattained packet the whole message
from the sender side is sent again to
the receiver end now let's look into
some details regarding advantages and
disadvantages of applying packet
switching advantage of using packet
switching is it provides rerouting in
case the network node is
busy it also allows multiple user to
access the same network and no
predestined path is
needed the disadvantage of applying
packet switching is the protocols that
are needed for the working of packet
switching is very
complex there are often cases of loss of
data packets during the transmission in
case of overloading or Corruption of
data now let's look into some
information about the Gob Back N arq
protocol this protocol applies the
sliding window method for transmission
of data in the network channel where n
in the protocol refers to the window
size assigned in the network
model as for the term arq in the
protocol refers to the automatic repeat
request which means the sender side will
send multiple data frames to the
receiver side according to the assigned
window
size and only after it receives an
acknowledgement from the receiver side
will it continue to send the frames from
the cender
side moving on let's look into some
important points regarding the
protocol as to begin with the method
applied to share multiple frames from
the sender site to the receiver s is
known as the protocol
pipelining where each frame is assigned
a sequence number for proper
transmission of data in the network
channel now let's move on to some other
important
points as we already know the n in the
protocol refers to the window size that
is the maximum limit of frames that can
be transmitted from the sender to the
receiver side before reaching the
acknowledgement for the previous
frame and in case if the transmission of
the acknowledgement of a frame is not
received within a certain time period
then all the frames from that sequence
number are to be retransmitted in the
channel this point is to be remembered
properly because this will be the key
point in solving a question related to
go back in arq
protocol
now let's move on to the working of the
protocol to begin with we have a sender
site under receiver side along with the
sequence number the window size for the
network channel and the number of frames
will already be assigned in the
network Now by applying the sliding
window protocol we will send the first
three frames from the sequence
continuously which will be frame number
zero frame number one and two
this is assigned according to the window
size after sending the frames we will
have a sliding window over the sequence
numbers that are 0 1 and
two after the frames are sent to the
receiver side it will use the frames and
send an acknowledgement signal to the
sender side that would be zero for the
first
time after which we we can share the
next frame that will be frame number
three from the sender side to the
receiver
side after sending frame three the
sliding window from sequence number 01
to2 to shift over to 1 2 and
three and similarly for frame number one
we'll receive the acknowledgement signal
from the receiver side to the sender
side and then we can share the next
frame that is frame number four from the
sender side to the receiver
side and the sliding window will shift
over from sequence number 1 2 and 3 to
over 2 3 and
4 as for the next frame that is frame
number two when we receive the
acknowledgement from the receiver side
there's a
catch for any network issues the
acknowledgement is not received by the
sender side so in this case as discussed
earlier in one of the important points
the sender side will not transmit frame
number five instead it will retransmit
frame number two three and
four where the second frame is the one
which did not receive the
acknowledgement and all the frames sent
after second frame is to be retr
transmitted along with it that is three
and four what is par bit
check the par bit is a data check bit
added to the original data for detecting
errors at the receiver Side by checking
the Integrity of the receive
data the parity bit adds one or zero to
the original data that is to be
transmitted to the receiver side
and if in case there's an error in the
receive data the center site will do the
parity check and give the request for
retransmission of the
data now let's move on to the key points
regarding par bit
check to properly understand the working
of par bit check we need to understand
some key point where the first one is
redundant bits they are the extra binary
bit that are added explicitly to the
original data to prevent the damage to
the transmitted data or to detect the
damage to the transmitted
data they are also used to recover the
original data in case of a damage at the
receiver
end the number of redundant bits added
depends upon the type of check method
used regarding which in this example
there are four datab bits used whereas
three redundant
bits it can also be two redundant bits
or one redundant bit in case of parity
check method only one redundant bit is
added to the original data now let's
move on to the next key point that is
parity
bits the parity bit check method is a
method to add bity bits to secure the
original
data that is done by counting the total
number of one once in the original
data which is either even or odd
number the par bit check method is used
to detect error in the original data at
the receiver side and also in some cases
it is used to correct the
change there are two types of parity
bits available to choose from the first
one is OD parity bit in this parity bit
check the number of ones in the original
data in including the parity bit should
be OD in number for example in the given
example the number of green tiles has
four ones that is even so the parity bit
should be one in this case to make the
total number of ones in the data five
that is odd similarly the other parity
bit is known as even parity bit in this
case of parity type the total number of
ones counted is to be even including the
par bit for
example the number of ones in green
tiles is four that is even so the value
of parity bit should be zero in this
case the point to be noted is the parity
bit value should always be correct
because it acts as the error detection
method at the receiver
site now let's move on to the explained
example to consolidate all the things we
have learned so
far
the question is for the given data bit
that is
110111 apply the even parity bit check
for data
transmission now let's begin for the
first step let's take the original data
that is 11 1
0111 and the parity bit value is to be
given as
P now according to the next step we have
to count the number of ones in the
original
data which will come out to
be five bits that means there are are
five ones in the original data which
represents an odd
number to balance this according to even
parity now we have to add one in place
of P so the new data to be transmitted
will become
110 111 and 1 which will be transmitted
to the receiver site by the sender
site after the data has reached the
receiver site there are a few cases that
may arise in the data where case one is
the data B received to transmission has
no errors that is the data received is
correct after applying the parity vid
check which in this case is even so the
transmitted data is this and the rece re
data is this that means both the
transmitted data and received data are
same that means theed data is correct
then the second case arises is the data
B received to transmission has errors
that is the data received is damaged
after applying the even parity check
which in this case the transmitted data
is and the received data has an zero
instead of
one which means that number of ones in
this case becomes five which does not
match with the even parity check so it
has an
error and the last Case Case three in
this the data bit received through
transmission has errors that is the data
received is correct according to the
even parity bit because the transmitted
data has six ones whereas the received
data has four ones but according to even
parity check only the number of ones
should be
even that means the number of ones
received by the receiver site is four so
according to parity bid check it is
valid
but according to the original data the
received data is
wrong these are the three main cases
that may arise during a transmission of
data through parity check method in this
interactive demo session on the top
networking commands we will look into
some of the most popular commands
applied by users to handle network
issues and save precious time so stay
tuned but before we begin if you love
watching Tech videos subscribe to our
Channel and hit the Bell icon to never
miss an update from us to begin
practicing the commands we need to
access the command prompt application
using the CMD command in the start menu
now let's begin with the list of
commands the first command is IP config
this command displays the system's basic
IP address configuration data which
includes Network information about IP
addresses subnet mask and default
gateway similarly we also have ip config
/all command which displays all the
details regarding our device like Lan
settings physical address of the system
IP addresses subnet masks and DHCP
information let's use the CLS command to
clear the application window for the
next one the next command is host name
which is used to access the systems host
name to verify this let's use the IP
config SL all command to check the host
name in the information and for sure we
have the same host name let's perform
the CLS command again and perform the
next
command the Ping command is used to
check the communication availability of
the destination host and the user system
for example use a ping command with
google.com to check the server
availability which gives us the
following
result also using the results IP address
and then the Ping command we can get the
same result in case we just don't have
the domain name we perform the CLS
command again and move on to the next
one the NS lookup command is used to
troubleshoot network connectivity and
find the IP address of a domain like
Google and Amazon as applied just now to
receive the name and address of the
domain also using the NS lookup command
and then applying the server command
with an IP address we can get the domain
name belonging to the IP address and
similarly to check the number of servers
with the same domain name we can do this
and we have four name servers for Google
we perform the CLS command again and
move on to the next one the tracert
command is used to troubleshoot the
routing issues of the network by
displaying the rou table through which
the data is transmitted to a maximum of
30 hops in the network as you can see
similarly you can also try amazon.com
and share your views in the comment
section below now let's clear the
application window and perform the next
command which is the ARP command this
command is applied to display the
communication exchange between the IP
address and the systems Mac or physical
address let's move on to the next
command which is the path ping command
this combines the Tracer and ping
commands and displays detailed
information as an output for maximum of
30 hops in the network this command
takes some time to compile the full hop
details so that you can share findings
in the comment
section next we have the net stat
command it's used to display the network
connection summary of the system as
shown in the demo similarly if we use
The netstat Hyphen n command it will
give us much more details about the
connection and UDP
details next we have the net share
command which displays the details of
where the data resources for our system
are shared and we can check them under
the share name resources and remark
column then we have the route command
that allows us to access the routing
tables and also allows us to make
changes to them let's try the route
print command and we have the interface
list ipv4 routing table details with all
the active roots and the IPv6 routing
table moving on it's clear the window
and look at the netsh command the netsh
is a popular command which allows us to
view and configure the network adaptors
in the system under the netsh command we
have multiple functions for configuring
settings let's try the show command and
we have the following
result moving on we have the task list
command that lists all the currently
working applications on the system with
task or program ID and the memory it
uses let's perform an example access
Google Chrome and then perform the task
list command and as expected we have the
Chrome details in the list and if we
close the Chrome window and again use
the task list command we don't have the
application active similarly we also
have the task kill command which will
terminate the task corresponding to the
given program ID in the command window
for example let's access Chrome and
perform the task list command to check
the program ID and then we'll use it
with the task kill command and we can
see that the application is terminated
to check our result we can access the
task list command again next on the list
we have the system info command it's
used to view all the information about
the system from the windows version to
the BIOS and booting configuration you
can access all these details using the
system info command and the last Network
command command for this session is the
wmic command for getting detailed
information on the ports and functions
of the system like CPU details and then
similarly we can check the bio settings
if you are someone who is interested in
building a career in cyber security or a
networking professional by graduating
from the best universities or a
professional who elicits to switch
careers with networking by learning from
the experts then try giving a short to
Simply learns postgraduate program in
cyber security with modules from MIT
schwar College of Engineering the course
link is mentioned in the description box
below that will navigate you to the
course page where you can find a
complete overview of the program being
opened introduction to the
algorithm the disra algorithm was
invented by etgar W disra this algorithm
was designed to find the shortest path
between the nodes of a communication
Channel
the distance algorithm is also used to
form a shortest part table for the given
graph and it works on the principle of
greedy
algorithm now let's move on to some key
points regarding the
algorithm the first key point to be
noted to solve a Dias algorithm is the
algorithm is closely linked to position
of the nodes in a
graph the next point is the attribute
value between the nodes of a channel is
used to deduce the shortest
path as for the last point we have the
initial value of all the nodes from the
current node is assumed to be
infinite to much practically understand
the functioning of the dxas algorithm
let's take a look at the principle for
the
same the principle of of the algorithm
works as if the distance of U that
represents the current node plus the
length that is the attribute value
between node U that is a current node
and node V that is the target node is
less than the attribute value to
distance of the target
node and also the distance of the target
node is equal to the distance of current
node plus the length between Target node
and the current
node where distance U represents the
source node or the current
node and distance V represents the
target node or the destination node to
much better understand let's apply
this for the given question let's find
the shortest
path in this given example we have three
different nodes node a b and
c using the previously discussed
algorithm principle we will deduce the
shortest path for Note 8 to the other
nodes in the graph that is the shortest
path from node a to node B and the
shortest path from node a to node
C for this let's take the node B first
according to to the solution it should
be for node B on applying the algorithm
along with the values we have if 0 that
is the position of a is zero plus the
target node attribute value that is 10
is less than equal to infinite that is
initially as mentioned infinite value is
to be
assumed and this statement stands true
so the distance between node note a to
node B becomes
10 for the third step we will look into
distance between node a to node C that
would be 0 + 40 that is the direct
connection between node a to node C
according to the example which is less
than infinity again true so the distance
between note a to note C Is
40 Moving on but we have to find the
shortest path so for this fourth step
comes into picture that is for node C
from node B on applying the algorithm we
have 10 that is the initial value of
node B and + 15 that is the attribute
value between B and node C which is 25
and is less than
infinity so the shortest path between
node a to node C becomes 25 instead of
40 which was given through step
three using the same scenario and same
steps we will solve a much difficult
question and understand how the
algorithm is
used then without further Ado let's move
on to the solved example using the txra
algorithm according to the given
question we have to use the distress
algorithm for the given graph and find
the shortest path from note a to node
C the point to be noted is we need to
find distance that is shortest between
node a to node C only now let's take a
look at the
graph and this is the given
graph with Note a at the current Note
and Note C is to be with the targeted
node but before we begin with the
solution for the given graph let's take
a look at some of the important points
to
remember the first point the distance of
node a from all the other nodes is
infinite in the starting step as
discussed earlier in the example
graph the next point is the node with
the shortest value will become the next
current
node
then we have this graph is done to
maintain a proper shortest path value
table which will be very helpful during
the solution of the graph now let's move
on to the
solution to begin with we will make
shortest path table
value that is given through
this with three columns in it node
column value column and previous node
now let's start with the actual
solution to begin with the first step is
to Mark the current note that is node
a then the nodes that are directly
connected to the current node that is
node B and node
D Now using the value distance that is
three for node a to node B and8 for node
a to node D we will update our
table where the point to be noted is
that we have updated the previous node
as a for both the nodes B and D moving
on now let's choose the next current
node that
is note B for the next case because the
shortest path in the given table is
three Which is less than 8 now the
directly connected nodes to node b r
node D and node D similar to the case we
did earlier we will Mark the shortest
distance from node B to node D and node
D let's deduce the
distance the distance between node B to
node D is 3 + 5 that is equal to
8 and then we have distance from node B
to node D that that is 3 + 6 so the
value is
9 now we will update our shortest path
table and the new table comes up to be
from node D to node B we have 8 and node
B to node e we have nine with the
previous node as
B moving on let's decide the next
current node that is
D because the shortest distance is 8 in
comparison to 9 for node
e so the new current node is node D and
the directly connected nodes to node D
is node e and node
F the point to be noted is the current
node is chosen only from the unvisited
nodes now for this we have distance
between node D to node e is 8 that is
the previous value we deduced plus 3
that is the distance between node D to
node D and the total value comes up to
be
11 then we have to node F from node D
that is 8 + 2 that is the distance
between node D and node F so the value
becomes 10 on updating the shortest path
graph table we have the new distances
that is node F has 10 value with the
previous node as D and there's no change
with the node D because in comparison to
8 11 is much
bigger moving on let's choose the next
current node that is node e because in
comparison to value 10 from node F 9 is
smaller now the node e is a current node
node and the directly connected nodes
are node F and node
C now let's find the value between node
C and node e that will be 9 + 9 that is
the distance between node e and node C
so the value totals come up to be
18 and for node F and node e we have 9 +
1 that is the distance between node e
and node F that comes up to be 10
now let's compare with the graph table
where node f is originally at Value 10
and again the value is 10 so there's no
change and C we have infinite and the
value 18 is much smaller so the new
graph would be something like this with
node c as 18 value and previous node as
e now let's decide the next current node
that is node F because because the
distance value is lowest in the given
graph that is 10 and for node C is
18 and the directly connected node is
node C then the distance comes up to be
10 + 3 that is
13 using this 13th value we can decide
the current value of C is 18 and the new
value is 13 in comparison 13 is
obviously less so the new Gra graphs
comes out to be for node C value 13 and
the previous node becomes
f with the completion of all the nodes
in the given graph we can deduce the
shortest path from node a to node C that
comes up to
be from node a to node D node D to node
F and node F to node C and the total
value comes up to be 13
with this we have covered all the parts
regarding the functioning and the
working steps involved in the Dix
algorithm if you have any questions
regarding the topic you can ask them in
the comment section introduction to
distance Vector
routing distance Vector routing refers
to the distance or the vector that is
between the neighboring nodes in a
network channel and the routing part
refers to the established route through
which data packets are transmitted in
the network
channel the other aspect of this routing
protocol in a network channel is to
determine the shortest path for a data
packet in the network to reach its
destination next we will look into some
key points regarding the routing
protocol for routing protocol three Prim
key points are to be
remembered first one being each router
in this protocol is designed to share
the vector data of each node throughout
the
network this step is done to maintain
proper circulation of data in the
network channel the next key point is
the routing pattern in the network
protocol that is the data shared by the
routers is trans mited only to those
nodes that are directly linked to a
particular
router the last key point is that the
routing protocol is designed in a manner
that it shares the updated Vector data
periodically at the network
channel now let's move on to the next
heading that is the algorithm used in
the protocol
the algorithm used in this protocol is
termed as bman fold
algorithm this algorithm defines the
shortest path that a data packet can
take to reach its destination node from
a initial
node where D of XY refers to the least
distance from a node X to node
y moving on on we have C of X comma V
where X's cost from each of its
neighboring V node is taken into
consideration then we have D of Vy this
is a distance of each neighbor from its
initial
node and lastly Min of V this is an
abbreviation we used to determine the
most shortest Vector after the solution
is obtained using the algorithm in the
next heading that is Network example we
will understand all the points used in
the
algorithm now let's design a network
model with five different notes that are
a b c and d with each node connected to
each other using different network
channel the numerical value use in the
network channel refers to the vector
count that is the distance from node a
to node b or to some of the node in the
network
channel in a network model each node
share its Vector data with its
neighboring node at a regular interval
as there are various updates in the
network
model this data is shared in a form of
routing table where three different
columns are used first being destination
colum second Vector column that is the
distance node and lastly The
Hop let's take a look at the neighboring
nodes for this
model for note a we have b and e as it
is directly interl to the node a
for node B we have node a and node C for
node C we have B and D for D we have c
and e and lastly for E we have node a
and node D these nodes represents only
the neighboring
nodes now let's solve an actual example
on routing protocol to clear all our
doubts and understand the key
points the example we will be taking to
solve
is this network
model the initial step to start solving
the network model using the distance
Vector routing protocol is to make
routing table for each of the
nodes let's make the routing table for
node
a this is the routing table for node day
where we have destination as a that
means destination is a from no day that
means the distance Vector should be zero
then we have destination as B let's take
a look in this given example there is no
given connection between A and B that
means this distance Vector would be
Infinity
then we have destination as C similarly
as node B there is no direct connection
between a and node C that means this is
also
infinity and same is the case with node
D and in the end we have node e that is
the only directly linked
node to note a that means the distance
given is five so the network Vector is
five let's make another routing table
for node
e this is the routing table for no let's
take a look in this routing table the
first is destination to node a according
to the network model given distance is
five so the vector value is five with
the Hop 2
a then we
have destination as node B according to
the model the distance Vector should be
four then we have destination as node c
as given there's no direct connection
between node e and node C that
determines the value would be
Infinity then we have node D which
represents direct connection with node e
and the value is 7 and last
ly e destination from initial Point e
would be zero
Vector now let's make another routing
table similarly for node
C Now using the same steps you can make
the routing table for the remaining
nodes that is node B and node
D now let's move on to the next step in
solving the routing issue
this step is known as update step in
this step we use the vector column from
each of the node to update the vector
column or the routing table for a
particular node in this part we'll use
node e Vector column to update the
routing table for node
a and the steps are using the algorithm
that is the Bellman fold algorithm
we used
earlier as we already know moving from a
to destination node a is always zero so
we won't be doing this step let's move
on to the next one that is moving from
node a to node B that would
be would be a comma e as we are using
Vector column of node
e plus and the distance used to reach E
from
b a comma e represents
5 and E to be represents four according
to the network model so the value is 9
similarly let's solve for a to c to a to
c we have a comma e plus destination
required to move from E to C according
to the network model we have note a is
only directly linked with node e so the
value would be five but there's no
connection between node e and node C so
the value would be
Infinity moving on we have a to d in
this case we have a comma e the value
would be 5 plus e2d that is a direct
connection and the value would be seven
so the total distance is 12
and the last one is a to e for this we
have a comma e that is directly the
neighing node the value would be
five so the new routing table for node a
is 0 9 Infinity 12 and
5 similarly let's take another node for
this for the next node we will take node
C
and we will update the routing table of
node C using its neighboring nodes that
are node B and node D according to the
network
model now how to do this step firstly
it's C to destination
a in case of node B we
have C to a that would be C comma B that
is a direct connection Plus distance
required from B to a according to the
network model we have C comma b as 6
Plus B2 a does not have any connection
that is infinity so the value would be
null then we have node D in this case we
have C comma D that is a direct
connection 3 plus D2 a that is again
Infinity as it is not linked directly to
node
a moving on we have destination as
B for node B we have direct connection
so C comma B value is six whereas for
node D we have C comma D that is
distance 3 plus D2 B that is infinity as
it is not directly linked with the node
B so again the value is
null then we have destination as C so
connection between C to C is
zero moving on we have destination at
node D that would be C to d as C to
d as there is no direct connection
between node B and node D so the value
is
infinity whereas for C2 D is a direct
connection for node D so the value would
be
three now for the last node that is is
node e in case of node B we have C comma
B plus b to e where the value for C to B
node is 6 and B to e is 4 so the sum is
10 and now in case of node D we have 3 +
7 that would be distance from C to D and
then D to e and the value would be again
10 so we can use any of the side to
reach the destination node
e by completing all the steps we have
the new table for node C similarly we
can find the routing table for all the
nodes
present now to look into some key points
we
learned for the initial step use only
the node distance of immediate
Neighbors nodes without distance that is
directly linked to each other is always
Infinity for the update step use the
vector table of the only neighboring
node we have for the initial
node and lastly to continue the update
step roughly n minus1 iterations are
used where the value of n is equal to
the number of nodes for example the mod
V took had five nodes that means we have
to do a loop of four iterations what is
hdlc let's take a
look the hdlc stands for high level data
link control refers to the bit oriented
Network protocol designed to connect
multiple Network system according to the
communication
requirement the hdlc model applies the
arq protocol for application and
establishes a full duplex Communication
channel between the network
devices moving on we have the different
types of hdlc stations
available hdlc stations can efficiently
be differentiated into three different
types where the first type is primary
station in this station it handles the
establishing and de establishing of the
primary data channel to share different
frames in the network channel known as
commands
it also performs the data management for
the
network moving on we have the secondary
station this station work under the
command of the primary station and the
frames issued by the stations are known
as
responses as for the last station we
have combined station as the name
suggests this type of station is
available for both commands and response
value
next we will look into hdlc transfer
models the hdlc protocol supports two
types of transfer models which are
applied according to the need of
Communication channel where the first
type is known as normal response model
or in short
nrm this transfer model combines the
primary station and the secondary
station in a point to-point or
multi-point configuration to exchange
commands from primary station and
responses from the secondary
station and response to the
multiconnection
moving on we have the second type of
transfer model which is asynchronous
balanced
model in this transfer model the
combined stations are installed in a
point too configuration for exchange of
command or responses from either of the
node moving on let's take a look at the
hdlc frame model and
types the data unit for sharing
information in the hdlc protocol is
known as
frames the hdlc frame consists of
multiple frame fields which may vary
according to the frame
type in general
the hdlc frame consists of five
different frame Fields where the first
field is flag field in hdlc each frame
starts with the flag field in the
configuration and is defined by an 8bit
octed sequence which is
01111 1 0 in the flag field moving on we
have the address field it encapsulates
the receiver's address in the field for
example if the frame is sent from the
primary station it contains the
secondary station's address and vice
versa next we have the controll field
this field contains the flow and error
control information in bite
format next we have payload or the
information field it carries the actual
information from the upper layer of the
USI
model and the last field is known as FCS
field this field stands for frame
sequence check and acts as an error
detection field in the hdlc protocol
which includes a 6bit CRC
check given is a frame format for an
hdlc protocol with flag in the both
ending and the starting point followed
by address field control field
information field and FCS
field now let let's take up a quiz to
understand all the things we have
learned so far the question is the hdlc
protocol functions under which network
layer in the USI model and the options
are application layer data link layer
physical layer and the network
layer you can give your answers in the
comment section now let's move on to
different types of frame models of
available in
hdlc the frame models in hdlc can be
classified of following three types
depending upon the control field value
of the frame where the first frame is
known as I frame the I frame stands for
information frame and is applied to
encapsulate the user information from
the upper layer in the model and then
transmit it to the network
channel note the first bit of of the
control field in this Frame is always
zero which also acts as an
identification point for I
frame moving on we have the S frame the
S frame stands for supervisory frame and
is used for error and data flow control
and does not contain any information
regarding the information field in the
format note for the S frames the first
two bits of the control field field is 1
and zero which acts as an identification
point for S
frame as for the last type of frame
model we have uframe the uframe stands
for unnumbered frame used for system
management and exchanging information
between connected network
devices with this we have covered all
the relevant information regarding the
hdlc protocol the checkm is one of the
most applied error detection method in
the network channel and is a bit based
format detection
method the checkm uses checkm generator
on the center side perform the checkm
method and the checkm checker on the
receiver side to check whether there's
an error in the data or not let's
continue with the next setting that is
why to apply checkm
method using the checkm method at the
center side the checkm value is added to
the original data to be transferred as
an error detection method whereas at the
receiver side it decodes the incoming
data from the sender side according to
the checkm method to detect any changes
in the given data now let's move on to
the working steps involved in the cheum
method there are various steps involved
in the checkum method let's take a look
at the first step that is the first step
begins at the sender side where we
divide the original data into K parts of
n
Bits contining with adding all the C
blocks we have
obtained then the addition result is
complemented using one's
complement the data now obtained is
known as the check sum
value next let's look at the step
two data transmission after we have
received the check sum value from the
check some method we will add it to the
front of the original data and transfer
it to the network channel to the
receiver
site now step three step three begins at
the receiver side that is it will divide
that is the receiver side will divide
the obtained original data plus the XM
value into clay blocks and then add all
the K blocks using addition
after that we will complement the
obtained data if the complement of one
comes out to be zero that is no errors
are received in the data and the
receiver will accept the data whereas
for case two if the result is not zero
the received data is
damaged so the receiver will discard
this data and request for retransmission
of data from the sender
side now after understanding all the
points regarding working of the checkm
method let's take a look at a solved
example to better understand all the
points the question is for the given
data perform the check sum
method this is how we divided all the
four parts each of these represents a k
block that is four blocks and eight bits
in each of the block that is n Bits now
for the first step that is at the send
aside we will add all the given
data so the value would come out to be 1
0 0 that would be
1 0 1 0 0 would be 1 0 0 1 1 would be 1
carry 0er so 1 carry + 1 means 0 + 1
carry again 1 carry + one means 0o and
one carry again 1 0 1 that is 1 carry 0
+ 1 + 0 means 1 so 1 carry is over on
the this side 1 + 0 is 1 1 + 1 is 1
carry 0 0 + 0 is 0 0 + 0 is 0 and 0 and
we have one carry over here so the
obtained data would be 1 Z with extra
bit as this now to resolve this issue we
will now add the the extra carry to the
obtained data from the addition part
that would
be 1 0 1 0 0 1 0
0 now at the cender side we will do one
compliment for the obtained addition
value that would come out to be 1 1 0 1
1 0 1 0 that is the check sum value now
this value addition to the original data
will be shared to the receiver side
where at the receiver side we will again
perform the addition method and the
value comes out to
be this along with two digits of extra
bit that is the carry again similarly we
will add this carry to the addition
value and get the new data that is all
ones now again going by the steps we
have to perform once complement for this
value obtained that comes out to be all
zeros that means the check sum value is
zero at the receiver side which
indicates that there are no errors in
the receed data by the receiver
side with this we have completed all the
points regarding working of the checkm
method now to better understand all the
steps let's take up a
quest that is for the given data find
the check some value where the given
options can be one of them you can give
your answer in the comment section what
is par bit
check the par bit is a data check bit
added to the original data for detecting
errors at the receiver Side by checking
the Integrity of the received
data the parity bit adds one or zero to
the original data that is to be
transmitted to the receiver
side and if in case there's an error in
the received data the center site will
do the parity check and give the request
for retransmission of the
data now let's move on to the key points
regarding parit
check to properly understand the working
of par bit check we need to understand
some key points where the first one is
redundant BDS they are the extra binary
widths that are added explicitly to the
original data to prevent the damage to
the transmitted data or to detect the
damage to the transmitted
data they are also used to recover the
original data in case of a damage at the
receiver
end the number of redundant bids added
depends upon the type of check method
used regarding which in this example
there are four data bits used whereas
three rendant bits
it can also be two redundant bits or one
redundant bit in case of par check
method only one redundant bit is added
to the original data now let's move on
to the next key point that is parity
bits the parity bit check method is a
method to add binary bits to secure the
original
data that is done by counting the total
number of ones in the original data
which is either even or odd
number the parity bit check method is
used to detect error in the original
data at the receiver side and also in
some cases it is used to correct the
change there are two types of parity
bits available to choose from the first
one is odd parity bit in this parity bit
check the number of ones in the original
data including the parity bit should be
odd in number for example in the given
example the number of green tiles has
four ones that is even so the parity bit
should be one in this case to make the
total number of ones in the data five
that is odd similarly the other parity
bit is known as even parity bit in this
case of parity type the total number of
ones counted is to be even including the
parity bit for example
the number of ones in green tiles is
four that is even so the value of parity
bit should be zero in this
case the point to be noted is the parity
bit value should always be correct
because it acts as the error detection
method at the receiver
site now let's move on to the explained
example to consolidate all the things we
have learned so
far the question question is for the
given data bit that is 11 1
0111 apply the even parity bit check for
data
transmission now let's begin for the
first step let's take the original data
that is 1
0111 and the parity bit value is to be
given as
P now according to the next step we have
to count the number of ones in the
original
data
which will come out to
be five bits that means there are five
ones in the original data which
represents an odd
number to balance this according to even
par bit now we have to add one in place
of P so the new data to be transmitted
will become 11 1 0 111 and one which
will be transmitted to the receiver site
by the sender
site after the data has reached the
receiver site there are a few cases that
may arise in the data where case one is
the data B received to transmission has
no errors that is the data received is
correct after applying the parity withd
check which in this case is
even so the transmitted data is this and
the received data is this that that
means both the transmitted data and
received data are same that means the
received data is correct then the second
case arises is the data bit received to
transmission has errors that is the data
received is damaged after applying the
even parity check which in this case the
transmitted data is and the received
data has an 0 instead of
one which means the number of ones in
this case becomes
five which does not match with the even
parity check so it has an
error and the last Case Case three in
this the data bit received through
transmission has errors that is the data
received is correct according to the
even parity bit because the transmitted
data has six ones whereas the received
data has four ones but according to even
parity check only the number of ones
should be
even that means the number of ones
received by the receiver side is four so
according to parity bit check it is
valid
but according to the original data the
received data is
wrong these are the three main cases
that may arise during the transmission
of data through parity check method the
Heming code method is a network
technique that is designed to detect
errors and corrects datab belits which
are transmitted during data exchange it
was first implemented by RW Hamming
hence the name Hamming
code this network technique is
implemented because during data
transmission there are often cases where
data loss or data damage occurs to
recover or detect the damage in the
original data we use Hamming
code in the next slide we will look into
some terms that are related to the
working of Hamming cord the first one
being redundant
bits these are the extra binary bits
that are added explicitly to the
original datab bit to prevent damage to
the transmitted data and also to recover
the original data in case of a damage at
the receiver
end in the next point we will look into
into some formula related to redundant
fits and how to add them in the Hamming
code the formula related to redundant
widths is 2 R more than equal to m + r +
1 where M refers to the datab bits in
the data and R refers to the Redundant
bits let's take an
example in case m is equal to 4 that
means the datab bits used are four we we
need to find the value of R using the
above formula let's deduce the value of
redundant
bits 2 R is more than equal to 4 + r + 1
2 ^ R is more than equal to r + 5 so
using this let's use r equal 0 if we use
that we will get a value 1 that is more
than equal to r + 5 but that is wrong
then using r equal to 3 that is 8 is
more than equal to
8 this way we conclude that the Hamming
code would be 7 bit data because the
value of R is three and M is
four now let's move on to the next term
related to Hamming code that is parity
bits the parity bit is a method to
append binary bits to secure that the
total number of counts of one in the
original data is either even number or
an odd
number let's take a look why do we
exactly use parity bits they are used to
detect error in the original data which
occurs during the transmission of data
through this method we can detect the
error at the receiver end and also
correct
it let's take a look at different types
of parity bits
available first one is even parity bit
in this case of parity type the total
number of ones counted is to be even in
the
count in case the count is odd then the
value of parity is
one otherwise the value should be
zero similarly the other parity bit is
known as odd parity bit for this parity
bit the total number of ones counted in
the original data should be
odd if that is the case the value of
parity bit should be zero and in case
the value of once in the original data
comes out to be odd then the parity
value would be
one now let's move on to the next
setting that is the working example of
the hemming code let's take a
look let's begin with the the steps to
be followed to solve a Hamming code
issue the first point being the position
of the parity WID is determined using 2
the^ N term where n represents the
number series 0 to n assigning the
position for parity bit using this
method would be more clear during an
example for the second point we have the
remaining positions represents the datab
bit
now let's try using the value of par bit
for n is equal to 0 that means 2 The
Power 0 is equal to 1 so all the bits
with one in the last position are used
to determine the
value of the par bit to better
understand the assignment value of
parity bit please focus on this
mentioned
table in this table we can take a look
at the last position position that is n
is equal to 0 and see the mentioned
number for P1 we can use a value 1
because n is equal to Z and the last
position value is one then is number
three because the last position bit is
one then similarly for number five
because n is equal to0 and the bit value
is
one so these three parity value can be
used for any equal to
0 similarly let's take a look when the N
is equal to 1 that means 2 ^ 1 is equal
to two so all the bits with one in the
second position are used to determine
the value of par
bit now let's take a look at the table
to identify the numbers related to this
parity bit value the first one being two
due to the presence of one bit in the
second position then we have P3 presence
of one bit in the second position
similarly the next would be number six
due to the presence of one bit in the
second
position similarly let's take a look at
when n is equal to 2 that means 2 to
the^ 2 is equal to 4 so all the bits
with 1 in the third position are used to
determine the value of par
bit and this would be four five and six
number please read the points very
carefully because next we will solve an
example to better clarify all the
concepts let's move
on the given example is the datab bit to
be transmitted is
1011 and we have to solve this using the
haming code method so the first step
would be applying the Hamming code
method and identify the given number of
datab bits that would be four according
to the question so the number of parity
bit would be three where the value would
be 1 2 and four according to the par of
P
expression that means we will get
something similar to this this
representation is in databits format
where the first position is for P1 par
bit the second for 2 to the^ 1 that is 2
P2 and the third one is for 2 to the^ 4
that is P4
parity and let's put the value that is
to be transmitted in the remaining
positions that would be P1 P2 1 P4 1 0
and
1 using this bit value we will deduce
the value of P1 P2 and P4 for data
transmission in this case we are using
even parity for the example that means
the number of ones should be
even let's take a look for P1 we have D1
D3 D5 and
D7 as mentioned in the earlier
slide so the value would be P1 comma 1
comma 1 and comma 1 according to the
datab bits Available To Us by the
question that means the value would be
one because the number of ones for P1 is
odd so to make it even the value of P1
would be
one similarly for P2 we have D2 D3 D6
and
D7 using the same method we will get
P2 1 0 1 so the number of ones for P2 is
even so the P2 value would be
zero next is for P4 the value is D4 D5
D6 and
D7 where P4 has 1 0 and 1 that means the
number of ones is even so again P4 is
equal
to0 Now using this we get the new bit
that is to be
transmitted that is 1 1 0 1 0
1 after Transmission in case let's say
at position five an error occur and the
value of one is converted to
zero to detect this error at the
receiver side we will use the Hamming
code to begin with we will use the
parity value to cross check the original
datab bit that means means let's do the
parity bit method for this receed data
so for P1 we have D1 D3 D5 and D7 so the
number of ones is odd that means the
value of P1 should be one to make it
even then for P2 we have D2
D3 D6 and
D7 so the number of ones is even that
means the P2 value would be zero now
let's move on for
P4 that would be 4 D5 D6 and D7 number
of ones is one that means odd so the
value of P4 would be
one now let's take a look at the results
that we obtained using this
method foremost this shows that the data
transmitted is damaged and we can detect
the error position using using this
method that is using the value of parity
BDS obtained where this will lead to 2
the^ expression that means 2^ 0 + 0 + 2
^ 2 that means
5 that matches with the Assumption we
took now to correct this error we can
use the position that we obtained that
is five and replace the zero value with
one
bit by doing this we will obtain the
original
data now let's move on to the first
heading that is Introduction to the
protocol the Stop and we protocol is a
type of flow control mechanism active in
the OSI model of the data link lay the
transmission of data applies only to the
noiseless
channels where a noiseless channel
represents an ideal Network channel
where no frames are lost duplicated or
hacked moving on we have the Stop and
rate protocol is unidirectional in
transmission of data that is either
sending or receiving data will only
takes place at an
instance for the third point we have the
Stop and rate protocol as the name
suggest is when the sender shares a data
packet to the receiver end then the
sender site has to stop and wait for the
receiver side to send an acknowledgement
before it starts sending the next data
packet with this point we are now
knowledgeable about the working of the
Stop and R protocol at an elementary
level now let's move on to the next
heading the next heading for for the
session is steps involved in the Stop
and we
protocol the steps for this protocol are
divided into two parts sender and
receiver
protocol let's start with the sender
side the first step is to transmit one
data unit at a time to the receiver End
by the sender side and the next step
is to transmit the next data until only
after we receive the acknowledgement
from the receiver
end now let's move on to the receiver
side in receiver site step one is to
receive the data and use the data that
is being
sent then the second step is after the
data has been used by the receiver site
it will send the acknowledgement to the
sender site for further data
transmission this is how the
transmission of data takes place in in
the data
protocol now let's move on to the next
heading that is working of stop and we
protocol using the previous two headings
we can easily determine the steps
involved in this working let's take a
look to begin with we have two sides the
sender and the receiver
side the first step is to send the data
from the sender side to the receiver end
and and after the receiver side has used
the data it will send the
acknowledgement
signal meanwhile the sender site has to
wait for the acknowledgement signal only
after it receives the acknowledgement
signal will it send the next data
packet now that the sender site has sent
the data for the second time the
receiver site will use this data and
then only share the acknowledgement
signal this process cess of sending data
from the sender side to the receiver
side and receiving acknowledgement from
the receiver side to the sender side
continues for a number of times
according to the given scenario in the
network
channel now let's move on to the next
heading that is also the last setting
for this session that is drawbacks of
using stop and read
protocol the first drawback of using
this protocol is the loss of
data this issue can arise when
transmitting data from the sender side
to the receiver end it may be due to any
issue due to hacking attempt or network
disruption or any other network related
issue then this can also arise when
receiving acknowledgement from the
receiver
site now let's move on to the second
drawback the next issue is related to
acknowledgement transmission that that
is during the transmission of
acknowledgement signal due to the
network issues the acknowledgement
signal is disrupted and the transmission
is
terminated this can arise again due to
any reasons that are occurring in the
network
channel now let's move on to the last
drawback for this
heading the last issue occurs due to the
delay in transmission time of the
information time delay drawback can
occur on either side of the transmission
that is during data transmission or the
acknowledgement transmission as we know
in a networking concept protocols refers
to the rules and
instructions that governs the data
transmission between different network
models and devices in a Communication
channel the data transmitted using
protocols is easily handled and is
reliable to use as well as it provides a
secure channel for the data to be
transmitted
now let's move on to the different types
of protocols available in a network
channel the protocols available in a
network channel can be divided into two
different types noiseless channels and
noisy
channels where the noise part refers to
any external interference data error or
duplicate Transmission in the network
channel furthermore noisess channels
noisy channels can be divided into
subdivisions let's take a look at the
noiseless channels
First noisess channels can be divided
into two types simplest type and stop
and weit type whereas noisy channels are
divided into three subdivisions stop and
wait arq go back and arq selective
repeat
arq in the noisy Channel go back in arq
and select Collective repeat arq are the
ones that apply the sliding window
protocol for data transmission over the
network
channel now let's look into some
information regarding sliding window
protocol to begin with the sliding
window protocol is a technique that
allows the share of multiple data frames
in a network
channel where the number of frames
shared is determined by the window size
assigned to the network
channel also the frames sent during
transmission are assigned with a
sequence number for efficient frame
Transmission in the communication
Channel till this point in the video we
have already learned about the
definition of what is the sliding window
protocol now let's look into the working
steps of the sliding window
protocol to begin with we have a sender
site and a receiver site in the the
network channel then we require the
frames where each frame is given a
sequence number for this example we are
using 0 to 8 which means a total of nine
frames are available at the cender
side then using the window size we
determine the number of frames that can
be shared at an instance for example
we'll be using three as a window size
for this
example let's start with sending the
first frame that is zero to the receiver
side after the frame is sent a sliding
window appears on the number of
frames now let's move on to the
next that is frame
one the point to be noted is before
receiving any acknowledgement we have to
send all the frames that are available
according to the window size that is for
this example the window size is three
that means we have to send three frames
before we receive any acknowledgement
from the receiver site let's send the
last frame that is frame
two now we have to wait for the receiver
site to send the acknowledgement signal
to the sender site before we can send
the next frame now that we have shared
the maximum number of frames the
receiver end will share the
acknowledgement signal for frame zero
with the sender side after this
acknowledgement is received by the
sender side we can share the next frame
in the list that is frame
three after the frame three has been
sent see the positioning of the sliding
window the sliding window now changes
from 012 to 1 2 and three
frame this positioning of the sliding
window represents that zeroth frame has
already been acknowledged by the
receiver site whereas the third frame is
sent for acknowledgement from the
receiver side by the sender
side and similarly we have to do the
same pattern for the next two frames
that is frame number one and frame
number two now the center side will
receive the acknowledgement for frame
one from the receiver
side and we can send frame four from the
sender side to the receiver
side now see the movement of the sliding
window the sliding window changes from 1
2 and three frame number to 2 3 and
4 similarly we can move on to the last
frame now let's draw some simple
conclusion from all the working steps we
have seen so
far to begin with frame number one and
zero represents the acknowledged
frames whereas the frames within the
sliding window represents the frames
that are waiting
acknowledgement whereas the remaining
frames 5 6 7 and 8 are not yet shared
with the receiver
site now let's move on to the next
heading for the
session difference between stop and
weight protocol and sliding window
protocol the first comparison is on the
basis of working mechanism where the
Stop and weight protocol is designed to
send the data frame at a single time and
wait for the receiver to send the
acknowledgement to share the next
frame as for the slighting window
protocol sender can send multiple frames
simultaneously and then wait for the
corresponding acknowledgement from the
receiver
end let's move on to the next comparison
that is based on the window size on the
basis of window size the Stop and rate
protocol is always fixed at one as for
sliding window protocol as we saw in
earlier slides it varies according to
the scenario in the network
channel let's take a look at some other
comparisons too the next comparison is
based on efficiency and time delay as
comparison on this basis the Stop and
rate protocol is efficiently low and ERS
from more time
delay as for sliding window protocol the
efficiency is higher than the Stop and
weight protocol which provides lower
time delay during data
transmission let's move on to the last
comparison sorting and transmission of
data for stop and waight protocol
sorting is not
required and it applies half duplex
system for data
transmission as for slide writing window
protocol we require sorting for better
efficiency and is full duplex in
nature with this we have reach the end
of the video now let's look into some
information about the Gob back and arq
protocol this protocol applies the
sliding window method for transmission
of data in the network channel where n
in the protocol refers to the window
size assigned in the network
model as for the term arq in the
protocol refers to the automatic repeat
request which means the sender side will
send multiple data frames to the
receiver side according to the assigned
window
size and only after it receives an
acknowledgement from the receiver side
will it continue to send the frames from
the sender
side moving on let's look into some
important points regarding the
protocol as to begin with the method
applied to share multiple frames from
the sender side to the receiver side is
known as the protocol
pipelining where each frame is assigned
a sequence number for proper
transmission of data in the network
channel now let's move on to some other
important
points as we already know the n in the
protocol refers to the window size that
is the maximum limit of frames that can
be transmitted from the sender to the
receiver side before reaching the
acknowledgement for the previous
frame and in case if the transmission of
the acknowledgement of a frame is not
received within a certain time period
then all the frames from that sequence
number are to be retransmitted in the
channel this point is to be remembered
properly because this will be the key
point in solving a question related to
go back in arq
protocol now let's move on to the
working of the
protocol to begin with we have a sender
site and a receiver site along with the
sequence number the window size for the
network channel and the number of frames
will already be assigned in the
network Now by applying the sliding
window protocol we will send the first
three frames from the sequence
continuously which will be frame number
zero
frame number one and
two this is assigned according to the
window
size after sending the frames we will
have a sliding window over the sequence
numbers that are 0 1 and
two after the frames are sent to the
receiver side it will use the frames and
send an acknowledgement signal to the
sender side that would be zero for the
first
time
after which we can share the next frame
that will be frame number three from the
sender side to the receiver
side after sending frame three the
sliding window from sequence number 0 1
to 2 will shift over to 1 2 and
3 and similarly for frame number one
we'll receive the acknowledgement signal
from the receiver side to the sender
side and then we can share the next
frame that is frame number four from the
sender side to the receiver
side and the sliding window will shift
over from sequence number 1 2 and 3 to
over 2 3 and
four as for the next frame that is frame
number two when we receive the
acknowledgement from the receiver side
there's a
catch for any network issues
the acknowledgement is not received by
the sender side so in this case as
discussed earlier in one of the
important points the sender side will
not transmit frame number five instead
it will retransmit frame number 2 3 and
four where the second frame is the one
which did not receive the
acknowledgement and all the frames sent
after second frame is to be
retransmitted along with it that is
three and
four to much better understand the
solution for the example we'll be
solving later in the video it is
suggested that you watch the steps
involved in the working of the go back
and arq protocol
again now moving forward let's take a
look at some of the advantages and
disadvantages of using the protocol in a
network
channel for advantages we have it
increases the efficiency of transmission
of
frames it also allows multiple frames to
be sent at
once and the time delay is low for
sharing the
packets as for this advantages we have
the tree transmission of frames in case
of an error in the network channel is a
very difficult
work and it also requires the storing of
frames on the receiver side that it
receives from the center
side now that we have learned everything
about the goack andq protocol let's take
a look at the much awaited working
example for the
same let's take a look at the problem
statement in a given Network the number
of frames provided is 10 with the window
size assigned as three and for every
fourth packet is
lost find the total number of messages
or frames sent from the sender site to
the receiver
site from this question we can get three
main parts that are the number of frames
that are given is 10 as for the window
size is three and every fourth packet is
lost let's take a look at the
options option a 27 option b 25 option C
22 and option D
29 I'll give you guys a moment to take a
look at the question
again now let's move on to the solution
as usual we have the sender side and the
receiver
side and according to the question we
have 10
frames numbering the frames sequentially
we have frame 1 to frame
10 and then according to the question we
have window size as
three Now using the sliding window
method we'll send the first three frames
that is frame number one 2 and three
from the center send side to the
receiver side that will
be like
this after sending the frames we'll wait
for the receiver site to send the
acknowledgement and a sliding window
will appear on frame number one 2 and
three now the receiver side will send
the acknowledgement for frame one to the
sender
side and using this we can send frame
number four from the sender side to the
receiver
side and a sliding window appear on two
three and four sequence
number and similarly for frame number
two we'll send the acknowledgement from
receiver side to the sender
side and send frame number five from
sender to the receiver side and a
sliding window appears on sequence
number three 4 and five then again for
frame number three we'll send the
acknowledgement from the receiver side
to the sender side and send frame number
six from the sender to the receiver side
and a sliding window appear on frame
number four 5 and six now let's move on
for the next frame for acknowledgement
that is frame number
four for this Frame according to the
given question every fourth frame is
lost during transmission from the sender
side to the receiver side
that means no acknowledgement will be
sent from the receiver side to the
sender side for frame number four in
that regards or any other frame that are
sent after frame number four that is
frame number five and frame number
six similarly frame number five and
frame number six will also get
discarded now let's retransmit according
to the go back and arq
protocol frame number four frame number
five and frame number six after
retransmission frame number four will
get acknowledged by the receiver site to
the sender side that means we can send
next frame that is frame number 7 from
the sequence
order and the sliding window appears on
frame number 5 6 and
7 similarly let's move on to frame
number five but before before we do that
let's count the position of fifth frame
in the transmission
order 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 and 8 that's correct
when we count the position number for
any of the frames from the beginning we
use sequence not the sequence number
given by the
question that means fifth frame is at
the position number eight from the
beginning that means according to the
question it will get lost during the
transmission from sender to the receiver
side
similarly frame number six and frame
number seven that was sent after fifth
frame will also get
discarded according to the go back and
arq protocol again we will retransmit
five six and seven frame number to rece
a site from the sender
site after retransmission frame number
five will get acknowledged by the
receiver site and then we can share
frame number eight from the sender to
the receiver side and the positioning of
the sliding window shift from 567 frame
to 67 and 8 sequence
number now let's move on to the sixth
frame but according to the positioning
order position of the sixth transmit
frame is number
12 that
means it will get lost during
transmission from sender to the receiver
side and similarly frame number seven
and 8 will also get discarded by the
receiver side and again applying go back
nrq protocol we will retransmit frame
number 6 7 and
8 on retransmission frame number six
will get acknowledged by the receiver
side and we can share frame number n
from the sender to the receiver
side and the sliding window will shift
from sequence number 67 and 8 to 78 and
9 now let's recount the position of the
next frame that is frame number seven
from the beginning and that would be 16
that means frame number seven will get
lost during transmission from the sender
to the receiver
side and similarly frame number 7 8 and9
is to be retransmitted
according to the go back and arq
protocol now similarly following all the
previous steps we can complete this
network model using go back in RQ
protocol but this is a work you guys
have to complete and find out the total
number of packets that were trans
transmitted from the sender to the
receiver
side and give your answers in the
comment section and the next heading is
what is selective repeat AQ
protocol for the first point in
selective repeat AQ protocol we have is
the working principle The Working
principle of the SRP protocol is based
on sliding window protocol and it uses a
buffer system for storing either at the
cender side or the receiver side during
the data
transmission let's move on to the next
point for Selective repeat
arq the term arq in the protocol defines
the automatic repeat request process
that is designed to perform the task of
sending the next frame for each of the
acknowledged
frame now let's move on the next
heading next heading is important points
about the
protocol for the first point we have
is the value of n that represents the
window size is same for both sides that
is the value of sender size is equal to
the window size of the receiver
side let's take a look at the next
point in case of selected repeat arq
protocol as the name suggest in case the
frame is not received by the receiver
side or the acknowledges not received by
the sender side as shown in the diagram
in this case the mentioned frame is to
be retransmitted without affecting any
other
frame let's move on to the next point
for this
heading
in case the frame is not received by the
receiver site then it will share a
negative acknowledgement signal to the
center side so that it can retransmit
the damaged
frame this point forms the basis of the
working process involved in the SRP
protocol so please take a note of this
point now let's move
forward with the working of the protocol
we'll divide the working process of the
SRP protocol in multiple steps for
better understanding let's move on for
the first
step to begin with we have a sender side
and the receiver side as
usual then we have a sequence of
numbers and our window
size now for the Second Step let's send
the First Data frame that is frame
zero next is frame
1 frame two and frame
three these four frames are sent for the
beginning because our window size is
four and a sliding window appears from
sequence number 0o to sequence number
three after the receiver side have
received the senderid frames it will
acknowledge the first frame that is Fram
zero and send the acknowledgement signal
to the sender
site after the sender site receives the
first acknowledgement signal it will
again share the next frame in the
sequence that is frame number
four and the sliding window will shift
from frame 0 to 3 to 1 to
4 now similarly let's acknowledge frame
number one from the receiver side to the
sender side
and the center side will share the next
frame in the sequence that is frame
number five to the receiver
side and the sliding window will shift
from frame 1 to 4 to sequence number
now let's acknowledge frame number
two okay now let's assume that frame
number two is lost or corrupted during
the
Transmission in this case if we apply go
back NQ protocol all the frames sent
after frame number two are to be
retransmitted that will be frame number
two 3 4 and 5 but in case of SRP
protocol that is selected repeat arue
protocol only the frame that is lost
during transmission is to be
retransmitted that means the
acknowledgement signal for frame number
three will be sent from the receiver
side to the sender side and the sender
side will then retransmit frame number
two to the receiver
side this process of retransmitting only
the last frame is known as The Selective
repeat arq
protocol and similarly we will
acknowledge the next frame that is frame
number
four and send the next frame that will
be frame number
six as you can see in this process of
SRP protocol the sliding window or the
window size clearly does not play any
particular
role with the completion of this slide
we are done with the whole working steps
involved in the SRP protocol now let's
move on to the next setting in the video
choose from over 300 in demand scales
and get access to 1,000 plus hours of
video content for free visit scaleup by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know
more the next setting in this session is
difference between selected repeat arq
protocol and go back in arq
protocol let's take a
look for the first point we
have in go back andq protocol it does
not require a large amount of memory as
it does not provide the buffer feature
for the network
model whereas in case of selective
repeat arq protocol it requires a buffer
system so the memory needed is more on
both the sides that is the sender side
and the receiver
side now let's move on to the next
Point all the frames after the Lost
frame in go back inq protocol are to be
retransmitted as we already discussed in
the earlier slide
light whereas in case of selective
repeat arq protocol only the damaged or
the loss frame is to be retransmitted
let's take a look at some other points
too in go back in your protocol too many
retransmission frames are required so
the efficiency of the overlord model is
very
low and in case of SRP protocol the
retransmission frames is less so the
efficiency of the overall model is
increased let's take a look at the last
point for the
difference the bandwidth required for go
back in AQ protocol is too high due to
the more retransmission
frames as for SRP protocol moderate
bandwidth requirement is
needed with the completion of difference
between SRP protocol and go back in RQ
protocol the user datagram prot protocol
commonly known as UDP protocol is
designed to be unreliable and
connectionless in nature which applies
process to process communication model
for data exchange between devices and is
active in the transport layer of the oi
model and is used to transfer data and
information related to internet services
over the network channel where process
to process communication refers to the
use of port numbers in the header format
during the transmission of data over the
network channel as for connectionless it
means that the UTP format does not
provide a established path for the data
to transfer instead it uses multiple
different paths which we will look into
further in the video let's move on to
the next
heading features of using user datagram
protocol the user datagram protocol
provides the network with various
efficient and easy to understand Network
protocol features to apply over the data
that is to be
transmitted where the first feature of
UDP is related to the working area that
is the UDP model is a transport layer
protocol of the USI model and is used to
deliver best effort delivery options for
the data transmission where the best
delivery option refer that the protocol
does not provide the sender will receive
any acknowledgement from the receiver
side for the data transmitter
or it does not provide any guarantee of
data transmitted to the receiver
site now let's move on to the second
feature of user datagram protocol the
second feature represents the mode of
delivery or connection that the UDP
establishes for data transmission the
UDP protocol as we know already
establishes a connectionless path that
means there's no actual virtual path for
the data to be
transmitted so that the each data from
the UTP format uses a random path
available in the network channel and
reaches its
destination now let's move on to the
next heading that is UDP header
format the UDP header format comprises
of two
parts first the UDP header part which is
8 bytes in size and second the data to
be
transmitted furthermore the header part
is divided into four different different
Parts Source Port destination Port total
length and check sum where each of the
parts are divided into 16
bits let's take a look at the different
parts of the header format in a little
detail the first one is Source Board
number it is a 16bit value that is used
to identify the port that is
transmitting the
data next is destination port number
that is used to identify the port number
that will be receiving the data on the
receiver
end next we have total length as the
name suggests this value is used to
specify the total length of the UDP
packet including the UDP header part and
the last is check sum this is a 16bit
value field and is used as an optional
attribute it is left empty if there's no
need or it is used in case where
accuracy of the data is to be
measured now let's move on to the
working of the UDP
protocol to begin with we have data from
the cender side which is enclosed with
the UDP header for communication and
data in the UDP header
part the next step is to hand over this
data over to the IP section
for ENC
capitalization with the IP header and
data with the UDP header and data
part as for the last step this part is
handed over to the frame section where
it is transformed with the frame header
and data
format moving on now let's Transit the
data over the network channel for the
receiver and to receive it over to the
receiver side first step is
decoding of frame header part and data
part into the IP section which contains
IP header and data
section again this IP packet is divided
into UDP header part and data part from
where the message is retrieved from the
data section of the UTP header format
and is then received by the receiver
end now let's move on to the application
of UDP
protocol let's take a look at some of
the features of the UDP protocol that
provides applications to various Network
models for the first one we have it
provides flow control and error control
mechanism to the network model such as
tftp next it provides faster
transmission of data as there's no
pre-established virtual path
needed so it is used for real time
Services life communication and gaming
Services now let's move on to the last
setting for this session that is UDP
versus TCP
protocol we will differentiate between
UDP and TCP based on some attributes
that are mostly used in a network model
and the first attribute is
reliability for UDP protocol as we
already know now now it is an unreliable
in nature that is it does not provide
any guarantee of data transmitted to the
destination side is reached or not as
for TCP it provides reliable and
guaranteed data delivery to the receiv
receiver
site the next attribute is
acknowledgement signal the UDP protocol
does not provide any acknowledgement
from the receiver side to the sender
side whereas in case of TCP prot protol
sharing the acknowledgement signal is
very important if the acknowledgement
signal is not shared by the receiver
side to the sender side the data
exchange will halt let's move on to the
next attribute that is connection mode
as we already know now UDP is a
connectionless mode of service there is
no virtual path established for the data
transmission to takes place whereas for
TCP protocol it is a connection oriented
protocol that is a virtual path is
needed for the data to be transmitted
over to the receiver site or the
destination
node the next attribute is error check
system in dudp protocol basic check
system is only used for error check
whereas for tcv protocol it is an
extensive error check
service and along with error flow
control mechanism included in the TCP
protocol
service let's take a look at today's
agenda
firstly we'll understand what exactly
the DCP protocol is then the allocation
methods in DHCP protocol next we will
understand some helpful DHCP settings
and lastly stepwise we'll understand the
operation model for
DHCP let's understand the DHCP
protocol the dynamic host protocol or
DHCP is a protocol that is designed to
assign the IP address to a device for it
to access the internet
this network model is based on the
client server architecture and removes
the process of manually assigning an IP
address to the system now let's take a
look at the allocation methods for the
DHCP
protocol the allocation method of DCP is
divided into two types the first type is
the manual allocation which as the name
suggest is the assigning of IP address
to the system manually by the user the
second method is dynamic allocation
which uses a client server architecture
to assign an IP address to the system
now let's see some points regarding the
allocation
method the first type is the manual
allocation as mentioned in this
allocation type the user manually
assigns the IP address to the system for
accessing the internet and can be
observed in this instance this is done
by accessing the network configuration
setting of the device and also requires
other related configurations such as
subnet mask preferred DNS server and
default gateway let's now take a look at
the dynamic
allocation in this allocation method the
client device receives all the relevant
Network configurations from the dscp
server and the system gets configured to
access the internet the provided IP
address is given for a certain period
which is also termed as the
lease now that we somewhat understand
what exactly the dynamic allocation in
DHCP server is let's take a look at a
small
example open the start menu and type
command
prompt when the windows open up type ip
config slash O
command as we see by this command we can
take a look at the network settings for
our
system over here we can see the DHC is
enabled that means the configuration
that has been used on the system refers
to the DHCP
server and on the bottom side we can
take a look at the different network
settings that are given along with the
IP address by the DCP server that is
subnet
mask default
gateway and the DNS
server now let's continue with the
video now let's take a look at some of
the notable DHCP
settings the first one is known as scope
as the name suggests a scope refers to a
range of addresses that are available to
a DCP server for allocation of the
client
device next we have is lease this
setting of The DHCP server is designed
to prevent the holding of IP addresses
by a single device this is done by
assigning an expiration date to the
least IP address so that the dscp server
has a minimum addresses left for the
client
device and lastly we have address
reservation in this DCP setting the
client device requests the server to
assign the same IP address to the device
each time the address allocation takes
place this is done by identifying the
MAC address of the client
device now let's take a look at the
operation model for DHCP protocol
the DHCP operations are performed under
user datagram protocol in short UDP
which is applied on two ports under UDP
which are ports 67 and
68 the first phase is where the client
broadcast a DCP server message over the
network to connect with the DHCP
server this message basically means that
it wants to connect to the internet
through the DHCP server the second phase
is when the DHC CP server receives the
DHCP message according to the message
the DHCP server reserves an IP address
for the client and network configuration
information including subnet mask
default gateway and preferred DNS
server in the third phase the client
responds to the DHCP servers offer
through a DHCP request message
requesting the offer IP address and
relevant network configuration for the
system then in the last phase the server
acknowledges the request broadcast from
the client and sends the DHCP packet to
the DHCP client which is comprised of
network configuration for the client
device to begin practicing the commands
we need to access the command prompt
application using the CMD command in the
start menu now let's begin with the list
of commands the first command is IP
config this command displays the
system's basic IP address configuration
data which includes CL Network
information about IP addresses subnet
masks and default gateway similarly we
also have ip config SL all command which
displays all the details regarding our
device like L settings physical address
of the system IP addresses subnet masks
and DHCP
information let's use the CLS command to
clear the application window for the
next one the next command is host name
which is used to access the system's
host name to verify this let's use the
IP config /all command to check the host
name in the information and for sure we
have the same host name let's perform
the CLS command again and perform the
next
command the Ping command is used to
check the communication availability of
the destination host and the user system
for example use a ping command with
google.com to check the server
availability which gives us the
following
result also using the results IP address
and then the pin command we can get the
same result in case we just don't have
the domain name we perform the CLS
command again and move on to the next
one the NS lookup command is used to
troubleshoot network connectivity and
find the IP address of a domain like
Google and Amazon as applied just now to
receive the name and address of the
domain also using the NS lookup command
and then applying the server command
with an IP address we can get the domain
name belonging to the IP address and
similarly to check the number of servers
with the same domain name we can do this
and we have four name servers for Google
we perform the CLS command again and
move on to the next
one the tracert command is used to
troubleshoot the routing issues of the
network by displaying the routing table
through which the data is transmitted to
a maximum of 30 hops in the network as
you can see similarly you can also try
amazon.com and share your views in the
comment section below now let's clear
the application window and perform the
next command which is the ARP command
this command is applied to display the
communication exchange between the IP
address and the systems Mac or physical
address let's move on to the next
command which is the path ping command
this combines the Tracer and ping
commands and display is detailed
information as an output for a maximum
of 30 hops in the network this command
takes some time to compile the full hop
details so that you can share findings
in the comment
section next we have the net stat
command it's used to display the network
connection summary of the system as
shown in the demo similarly if we use
the netstat hyphen n command it will
give us much more details about the
connection and UDP
details next we have the net share
command which displays the details of
where the data resources for our system
are shared and we can check them under
the share name resources and remark
column then we have the route command
that allows us to access the routing
tables and also allows us to make
changes to them let's try the route
print command and we have the interface
list ipv4 routing table details with all
the active roots and the P V6 routing
table moving on let's clear the window
and look at the netsh command the netsh
is a popular command which allows us to
view and configure the network adapters
in the system under the netsh command we
have multiple functions for configuring
settings let's try the show command and
we have the following
result moving on we have the task list
command that lists all the currently
working applications on the system with
task or program ID and the memory it it
uses let's perform an example access
Google Chrome and then perform the task
list command and as expected we have the
Chrome details in the list and if we
close the Chrome window and again use
the task list command we don't have the
application active similarly we also
have the task kill command which will
terminate the task corresponding to the
given program ID in the command window
for example let's access Chrome and
perform the task list command to check
the program ID and then we'll use it
with the task kill command and we can
see that the application is terminated
to check our result we can access the
task list command again next on the list
we have the system info command it's
used to view all the information about
the system from the windows version to
the BIOS and booting configuration you
can access all these details using the
system info command and the last Network
command for this session is the wmic
command for getting detailed information
on the ports and functions of the system
like CPU details and then similarly we
can check the bio
settings let's start off with question
one what is the OSI model explain the
different layers of the OSI model OSI
largely is a theoretical model uh
utilized to understand networking and
how data packets are created and how
they are being processed by a computer
this is normally used by the tcpip the
transmission control protocol over
Internet Protocol software suite so OSI
is known as the open systems
interconnection model it is a reference
model that describes how applications
are going to interact via the computer
network there are seven different layers
that we need to understand they are as
follows so in this diagram there are
these seven different layers we start up
from the bottom first is the physic
physical layer the data link layer
Network layer transport layer session
layer presentation and application when
uh such a question is asked in an
interview it is not only that we
identify these seven layers explaining
what the OSI model is in the first place
we then try to identify these seven
layers and we give a brief description
about each and every layer if there are
any additional questions they will come
after uh this basic
question so let's start off with the
physical lay this is the lowest layer of
the OSI model now this is where any and
every physicality of your computer comes
into the picture so it could be an uh
network interface card it could be an
RJ45 or a CAT 5 cable anything that
allows data to be transmitted physically
from your machine to another machine
next comes the data link
layer so on the data link layer as far
as networking is concern we just need to
understand that data packet is encoded
decoded into bits at this layer this is
also the layer that deals with Mac
addressing so the physical address of
every network interface card which is
the MAC address which is utilized to
Route data package over the network this
is where the MAC address resides on the
data link layer the next layer is the
network layer here datagrams are
transferred from one to another the
function of this layer are routing and
logical addressing the moment we talk
about routing and logical addressing IP
addresses come into the picture IP
version 4 IP version 6 so Network will
deal with IP addressing and the routing
of those packets then comes the
transport layer this is the layer
responsible for end to end connections
that automatically signifies that this
is where TCP and UDP will be working TCP
stands for transmission control protocol
UDP for user datagram protocol TCP is a
connection oriented protocol whereas UDP
is a connection list protocol these two
Protocols are utilized to estabish
establish connectivity between two
machines TCP is a more reliable method
of connectivity because there are a lot
of packets that are sent across to
verify that the data has been sent data
has been received and so on so forth
whereas UDP is a connection L protocol
where data is just dumped without
verifying whether the receiver actually
receives that data or not so in a
nutshell on the transport layer TCP and
UDP make their appearance and this is
where that functionality lies then comes
the session there this control signals
between the computer it establish
maintains and terminates connections
between processes so in the transport
layer we talked about TCP and UDP UDP
being a connection less protocol where
data is just transmitted without
verifying whether the receiver received
that data or not whereas TCP we studied
is more of a reliable protocol does
there are different packets signals that
will be sent across to verify that data
has been transmitted it has been
received properly and and then the next
uh segment of that data is being sent so
those control signals are established
using the session layer so the three-way
handshake of TCP the acknowledgement
packets and uh those kind of packets
will be taken taken care of on the
session layer of the OSI
model then comes the presentation layer
the presentation layer is responsible to
translate data into the application
layer format so the formatting right MIM
or coding that is being utilized the
utf8 character set that we utilize for
presentation encryption mechanisms all
of these work on the presentation layer
and finally comes the application layer
where the application itself uses a
particular protocol so that the other uh
machine on the receiving end the
application on that machine will be able
to understand what the communication was
about right so in a
nutshell if if I start from up top the
application layer will deal with any of
the data that the
application uh is generating so maybe an
user input you're logging in you're
typing the username password all that
data will be constructed let's say into
an HTTP or https format that's where
application layer comes into the picture
then the formatting of which into
utf8 uh and the encryption of which
would be done at the presentation layer
then this uh transport L and the session
layer would kick in to establish a TCP
session do the three-way handshake
establish that connectivity IP
addressing would be done on the network
layer Mac addressing will be done on the
data link layer and when everything is
ready on the physical layer the packet
will be sent out at the receiving end
the packet will be received on the
physical layer and then all these layers
will be reversed and finally at the
application layer the data would be
presented to the application who would
then execute it and showcase it on the
screen of the recipient
so this is the way you want to explain
this question you want to be very
concise precise about what you're
explaining you don't want to go into too
hypothetical scenarios you don't want to
delete Al with the layers you just want
to give the basic functionality want to
demonstrate that you understand what the
OSI layer is how the computer functions
and you want to move on from there if
the interviewer has any further
follow-up questions they will ask those
specific questions so that's question
one moving on to the question two
question two is Define unicasting
multicasting and
broadcasting now this is a question
which can be very lengthy but again most
of your interview questions are designed
that way it's basically to understand
how much conceptually you are aware
about these Technologies so you have to
be very concise don't go uh rattling
about technology too much but in a
concise manner just try to explain what
these things is so when data is being
transmitted over a network it can be
trans transmitted either in one of these
particular manners it can either be a
unicost multicast or a broadcast so what
is
unicost unicast is when a message is
sent from a single user to a single
receiver so one to one right so uh one
machine talking to another machine and
nobody else so also known as Point too
Communications one point to on the point
if you have to send information to
multiple receivers then you will have to
send it using multicast
right so this is where your multicast
networking comes into the picture so in
our case uh let's assume it's a network
where there are uh there's a Class C
Network approximately 255 odd machines
and Within These there are two machines
that want to talk to each other if they
want to talk between each other it would
be a point to-point communication where
they will utilize unicast where only
these two machines will have visibility
of that conversation and the other
machines will not even realize that this
conversation is taking place
if one machine wants to talk to multiple
machines then the multicast comes into
the picture as the name suggests in this
mode of communication data is sent from
one or more more sources to multiple
destinations multicast uses the internet
group management protocol also known as
the igmp protocol to identify groups so
under this igmp protocol various groups
are created where machines are
subscribed to those particular groups
and whenever message needs to be sent
through those groups it will be
identified by the igmp protocol and then
that particular message will be sent to
those multiple machines that are members
of those particular
groups and then comes the broadcast the
third method is known as the broadcast
as it says it is going to broadcast to
all so this is one to all that is
communication between a single user and
it is going to be sent to all the
machines in that particular Network
right so the three ways unicast is one
to one multicast is one to many and
broadcast is one to all then question
number three what is DNS DNS stands for
domain name system it is like the
internet's phone book that is
responsible for mapping the domain name
into its corresponding IP address and
let me give you an example over here
whenever we go and open up let's say a
browser a Google Chrome browser we type
in
www.google.com and then we press enter
and magically Google comes in front of
us the website
rather now how does the computer know
who Google is because as far as we are
concerned humans understand Google and
words like that computers don't
computers deal with binary zeros and
ones right and as far as Internet is
concerned they will only deal with IP
addresses and Mac addresses so how does
a computer know how to find google.com
and where is it located so the moment we
type in
in the browser window in the address bar
google.com and press enter a DNS query
is generated automatically by the
browser where a packet is sent to our
DNS servers asking what the IP address
is so in short DNS resolves domain names
to their corresponding IP addresses
there is a DNS server which will have
this index a data base of all the
domains associated with their IP
addresses if one particular DNS server
does not have that information that
you're looking for it may query another
DNS server who may have that particular
response so the first thing is when you
type in domain name it gets resolved
with the DNS it identifies the IP
address corresponding to that particular
domain name and thus allows the computer
to route that packet to the particular
server where that domain name resides so
in this scenario if you look at the
screen on the local PC you have typed in
cyers security.com there's a DNS
resolution that a query that goes to the
DNS server what is the IP of cyers
security.com the DNS server looks it up
in its particular uh database if it has
the corresponding IP address it will
then respond back the IP address is
2521 after which the packet is sent off
to cyers security.com moving on to the
question number four what is a
firewall now this is a very good
question and normally a very basic
answer that ever heard is that a
firewall is a hardware and a software
firewall but that's the functionality of
a firewall that is what how you can
install a firewall but there are
different types of firewalls and there
is a specific functionality that a
firewall is created for right so a
firewall is either a hardware or
software but its responsibility is for
blocking either incoming or outgoing
traffic from the internet to your
computer they secure a network so
essentially the firewall will allow a
connection to happen or or does allow a
connection to happen it won't go beyond
that that's the basic functionality of a
firewall okay so based on the
configurations that you have done based
on the rules that you have created on a
firewall it will then based on those
rules identify whether some traffic is
allowed in that Network or some traffic
is to be blocked from entering that
Network so as the screen shows the
firewall rules will analyze whether the
traffic is good if yes it will allow if
the traffic is bad it will block the
traffic and not allow that connection
from happening in the first place now
there are few common types of firewalls
that also need to be included in the
answer to this question and the first
one is a packet filtering firewall these
are the most common types that you will
come across which analyze packets and
lets them pass through only if they
match an establish security rule set now
here people do get confused when we say
that we analyze packets people think
that these firewalls will analyze the
contents of that packet which is not
correct when a definition for a packet
filtering firewall says that these
firewalls analyze packets it means that
they are only analyzing the source and
destination IP addresses port numbers
and the protocols that are mentioned in
those packets these firewalls do not
have the capability of De packet
inspection or DPI as it is known if that
capability comes into the picture you're
basically looking at an intrusion
detection system or intrusion prevention
system in today's world called as a
nextg fireball
okay so a packet filtering firewall
essentially will only analyze data
packets for its source and destination
IP addresses port numbers and the
protocol that is being utilized it will
then map that information to the rules
that are there on the firewall and based
on those rules it will either allow that
connection to happen or disallow that
connection from
happening the second type of is a proxy
fire wall these firewalls filter Network
traffic at the application Level So when
you say application Level they work at
the layer seven of the OSI model packet
filtering firewalls since we have
mentioned that they work on IP
addressing and port numbers will work on
the network layer of the OSI model also
on the transport layer because they also
look at protocols proxy firewalls will
work at layer 7even which is the uh
application layer of the OSI model and
will deal with application Level
protocols such as htdp https FTP SMTP
and so on so
forth and the third one is a state full
multi layer inspection firewall these
filter packet at the network transport
and application layers so they basically
do the job of the first and the second
type of
firewalls the packets are compared to
known uh trusted packets but now the
first question is if there is a stateful
multi-layer inspection firewall why do
we have type one and type two firewalls
like packet filtering and pro proxy
firewalls that is because that is how
the firewalls have evolved we started
off with the packet filtering then we
added functionality to it and so on so
forth so if a question comes what is a
firewall you start off with the option
saying it is a hardware or software this
is the responsibility the functionality
of a firewall is to allow good traffic
and disallow bad traffic based on the
rules that have been configured on the
firewall and then you got basically
three types of firewalls packet
filtering proxy and stateful multilayer
and just include a brief description of
each of these firewalls if getting your
learning started is half the battle what
if you could do that for free visit
scaleup by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
then moving on to question number five
what is a VPN VPN is also called a
virtual private Network it is a
connection between a VPN server and a
VPN client so it basically creates a
encrypted tunnel between the client and
the VPN server which is then utilized to
secure the connections that you're
making with the internet so as you can
see in the diagram the user has a VPN
client installed on the machine the VPN
client then creates an encrypted tunnel
to the VPN
server and through this tunnel encrypted
data is transmitted which can then be
processed by the VPN server uh sent to
the internet information can received
can be received back by the VPN server
the VPN server will encrypt that data
back and send it back to the user so if
there's a man in the middle attack that
is happening or a hacker trying to eases
drop on the communication mechanism they
will not be able to do so because of the
encrypted Tel it is very difficult to
decrypt this or hack through this
encrypted tunel the it is possible but
it is very difficult to achieve that
moving on to question number six what
are the advantages of distributed
processing now before we go into
advantages of distributed processing we
first have to understand what is
distributed processing so it is a term
which describes various computer systems
that use more than one processor to run
an
application here multiple computers
across different locations share the
same processor the advantages of
Distributing processes are as follows
but before we go into the advantages
distributed computing is basically where
multiple machines will pull their
resources together to run a singular
application so an application that has
multiple resources and can scale up and
scale down as and when required the
advantages are that it can be very uh
very useful in data recovery for example
raid where you're striping data on
various hard disks it is reliable it is
cheaper lower cost can be achieved and
it is easy to expand because of the
scalability factor that we just talked
about if there is loss of data in one
computer it can then be recovered by
another interconnected computer and one
of the examples would be blockchain in
today's world right what is blockchain
that this data is uh created live and
stored on a connection of computer so if
one of the computers Compu goes offline
the other computers in that network will
still have that data and the the
blockchain will still function without
any issues the second point a glitch in
one machine does not affect the
processing as there will be multiple
other machines like we discussed in the
blockchain several cost- effective mini
computers are used instead of costly or
Mainframe Machin so instead of having a
server bank I can have multiple machines
connect interconnected together and they
can function in that particular
blockchain or for that particular
distributed processing
mechanism depending on the amount of
data processing more computers can be
attached to the network thus you can
increase the number of computers that
can be a part of that blockchain or you
can reduce them as and when necessary
moving on to question number seven what
is
tcpip tcpip or transmission control
protocol over Internet Protocol is a set
of communication protocols that are used
to interconnect networking devices on
the internet this protocol defines how
data should be transmitted over the
internet by providing endtoend
Communications so essentially if you
want networking to be established on
your machine you will need
tcpip without TCP IP there will be no
work groups there will be no domains
basically your interconnectivity will go
for a toss tcpip is a software that once
installed on your machine will then
interact with the hardware which is your
network interface cards and then your
switches wires cables and all those
through protocols that have been already
pre-configured in it so with the tcpip
suite of softwares you will have all the
protocols all the functionality of the
OSI layer and each and every protocol
that works on each and every layer will
be predefined and pre-configured to work
in a particular manner the Internet
Protocol is all about routing each
individual packet to make sure it
reaches its destination so with the TCP
you're talking about the protocols that
will allow you to format the data and
generate it so that you can communicate
it over the network the IP will then
deal with the route in of those packets
so that the packet can be routed to the
correct computer and be received by the
recipient so the tcpip model is the
compressed version of The OSI mod the
seven layers will get converted into
four layers the network access layer
internet layer transport layer and
application layer going on to question
eight what do you mean by ip config and
if config both of these are commands the
first one on a Windows machine the
second one on a Linux machine so ip
config is known as the Internet Protocol
configuration
this is a command that is used on the
command line interface of Microsoft
Windows to view all the adapters and the
configuration of each and every adapters
for their network interfaces so as you
can see on the right hand side in the
command prompt screen if uh once you
type in the IP config command on the C
prompt and press enter it will give you
a list of all the adapters that are
there so you can see wireless LAN
adapter local area connection the media
is disconnected it doesn't exist at the
bottom you'll see the Wi-Fi connection
wireless landan adapter and it can give
you the IP version 6 IP address IP
version 4 address the subnet mask and
the default gateway so this is the
configuration that allows the machine to
know on what network it is on what is
the default gateway for communicating to
the internet what is the subnet mask so
how many computers may exist in that
particular Network and what is the IP
address of that specific computer so
that it can communicate across the
network as well if config is the same
thing on the Linux Mac or Unix operating
system so the command will also give you
the list of interfaces and the
configuration of each and every
interface it is used to configure
control the tcpip network interface
parameters from the command line
interface it allows you to see the IP
address of these network interfaces so
here you can see uh
the wlp1
19s the IP address being 192 168
43215 subnet marks being
255.255.255.0 with the broadcast being 1
43255 question n what is the difference
between a domain and a work group this
can be a very interesting question and
can be a very lengthy question at the
same time a work group is nothing but a
decentralized network where you have
interconnected multiple machines
together and each machine acts in its
own individual capacity thinks of itself
as a server right so a decentralized
network you every user manages the
resources individually on their PC so
local users on their own PCS managing uh
the network shares what can be shared
from that particular machine what data
should be shared should not be shared to
whom it can be shared with and so on so
forth it is good if you got a small
network uh a few machines alog together
uh and you want them to interact with
minimal management effort right so each
computer each user will decide what they
want to to allow other users to see on
that particular Network and all of them
would be connected over a land a local
area network either a wireless or a
wired one so if you look at your home
Wi-Fi right now that is one of the best
examples of having a work group The
Domain on the other hand is a
centralized Network model so in a
corporate environment whenever you go
there and you got a domain based
username and password which when entered
onto a particular machine gives you
access to the entire network or whatever
applications and whatever resources have
been allocated to you that is where the
domain comes in so it it also uses a
single sign on mechanism for all the
resources that are that are to be made
Available to You whereas in a work group
you're a local user only meant for that
particular computer right so coming back
to the domain it is an administrator
who's going to manage the entire domain
and all of the resources connected to
the domain the resources could be
switches routers servers data stores
applications web servers Mail Exchange
servers and so on so forth so all of
these are administered by an
administrator through the domain it is
the most reliable and the optimum
solution for a large Network where
multiple users are going to interconnect
and share that data amongst each others
right the computer can be connected to
any network that means you can be on the
internet and through the internet using
a VPN you can connect to your corporate
Network authenticate in and get access
to whatever sources you are allowed to
access whereas in a work group you have
to be a part of that Network to access
that particular network if you change
your location you go and connect to
another Wi-Fi you will lose access to
your previous Wi-Fi then the last
question for the networking uh section
what is data encapsulation in networking
data encapsulation refers to the process
of adding headers and trailers to the
data the data link layer binds each
packet into a frame that contains the
hardware address of the source and the
destination computer so in this example
when you're talking about data
encapsulation we have talked about how
data that has been created by the
application layer we have a header and a
trailer that will give the various
informations of where that data needs to
be sent so the hardware address which is
the MAC address comes into the picture
and gets added to the header and the IP
addresses port numbers and all of those
things would then be added to this uh
trailers as well so that the data can be
then routed to the intended recipient of
that particular communication and there
you have it our introduction to the
exciting world of networking for cyber
security I hope you are as enthusiastic
as we are about this journey remember
building a strong foundation in
networking is the key to securing your
digital world if you found this video
helpful or you are excited to learn more
about networking and cyber security
don't forget to give it a thumbs up and
share it with your fellow Learners stay
tuned for more upcoming videos and we'll
dive deeper into the essentials of
networking and how they relate to cyber
security together we will strengthen
your skills and knowledge step by step
thanks for watching until then stay
curious stay secure and keep exploring
the fascinating world of cyber
security staying ahead in your career
requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domain
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know
more hi there if you like like this
video subscribe to the simply learn
YouTube channel and click here to watch
similar videos to nerd up and get
certified click
here